the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
the temperature is rising and the games
are heating up at the saint louis rapid
and blitz fireworks were flying over the
boards with explosive play yielding
decisive results american veteran sam
shankland is on fire winning two in a
row to take seoul second place and
challenge for the lead alareza perugia
faced off against fellow countrymen and
co-leader maxine bashir lagrave in a
final round matchup that quickly fizzled
into a draw securing a french tie at the
top the rapid section is over and we're
on to blitz who will catch fire in the
faster time control
day four of adrenaline packed chests
coming up next
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back everybody to day four of
the st louis rapidan blitz it's been a
fantastic event so far but this is it
today we're starting the blitz section
is going to be fast and furious action
let's go to the studio and start today's
rounds with yasser and peter
greetings live from saint louis the home
of chess in america and we welcome you
to day four of the saint saint louis
rapidom blitz
fourth stop on the granchester 2022
hello i'm peter svitler and with me is
yasaseeravan on a scale of one to ten
how excited are you for today
on a scale of one to ten i'm at a nine
i'm dialed up i'm dialed up this is
dialed up oh yeah correct
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to our live
coverage of the 2022 st louis rapid and
blitz
the rapid ended with a bang each round
of the rapids on the final day had three
decisive games and by the time the dust
settled we had a tie for first peter do
the honors tell us about our current
standings let's take a look at the
pairings
the uh pairing standings yeah standing
so at the top there you see the two
frenchmen alireza feroza and maxine
machella grab on 11 out of 18 and there
is a led from the very beginning and
embl caught up with him at the start of
day three and stayed with him in clear
third on ten points is the american sam
shanklin and that's with his loss in
round nine actually he was tied for
first prior to that loss to wow uh to
jeffrey shong and then we have nippom
nishi mamidarov and jeffrey on 50
and a bunch of
legends of the game there below 50
percent with five billion in the year on
minus one and hikaru in dead last
currently on seven out of 18 which is
honestly shocking considering he won
this event very comfortably last year
absolutely absolutely a shout out to
shaq with his perfect result and our
format
the format is a template around robin we
are done with rapid now uh that problem
robin has concluded and we're going to
play two blitz round robins uh time
control will be five plus two to second
increment after each move draw first
still not allowed and starting from this
round we will see fractals because we're
back to normal scoring system a point
for a win half a point for a draw and
obviously still no points for a loss a
remaining schedule
uh the schedule is we have nine rounds
of blitz today and nine rounds of blitz
tomorrow with colors reversed
if two or more players at diaper first
there will be a a playoffs and closing
ceremony uh more or less immediately
after everything is completed
as always we're delighted to have
christian in studio christian good to
see you my friend you're gonna drill
down on our co-leaders
good to see you guys great to be back in
the studio for a day for this is it the
action is going to get fast and furious
but first let's take a look at our
co-leaders and how they got to where
they are right now the co-leaders are
maxine vashir lagrav and ali reza firuja
the two frenchmen who came to the united
states to conquer let's take a look at
mvl's scoreline well there's no zeros in
that score line he hasn't lost a single
game up to this point a big victory in
round number three and another huge
victory in now round number seven to
start off day three allowed him to be in
the co-lead position with young alireza
who actually was leading the tournament
up until the last day well it very
that's a very nice line score he started
off with two important victories
unfortunately for him that round five
loss against fabiano caruana allowed
maxine vashir lagrav to catch up with
him
while he has a big smile on his face
this morning he's ready for fast and
furious action and we know how big of an
expert he is in the blitz portion let's
take a look at the live ratings as we
enter this event we see a tie at the top
that is quite unusual levon aronian and
hikaru nakamura who is having a sub-par
tournament for his standards he actually
lost 47 rapid rating points going into
the blitz section 28-50 at the top of
the standings caruana closely behind
28-47 needless to say this is going to
be a very competitive clash between
these players we're going to have a lot
of fun guys
it's a new day for hikaru a new shirt
he's sporting his pineapple shirt there
you go there you go and obviously taking
taking things very very seriously no
restriction of arm movement exactly nice
to see people recognizing that
those you know
little little bits of time
time you might lose if you so we have
formal we have we have sun flowers
sunflowers yeah yeah yeah and jan is is
jan sporting his uh his daughter shirt
this doesn't look like his delta shirt
he has a
is one
dota dota
yeah it looks like a paint splash on
that one uh our pairings for this first
round of blitz uh peter lay the table
what can we expect uh plenty of really
really nice pairings there uh
on a normal day a game between hikaru
and fabi will be absolutely absolutely
the big but i think the game of the
round has to be the one between ferrous
and bom nishi uh with with some backups
because we do have to this being blitz
concentrate program one game per round
and cover that
to almost the exclusion and everything
else but we don't we also have leonardo
playing against jeffrey shong sam
shanklin uh white against linear
dominguez and shakiram midarov
playing mdl right so we will keep
an eye on those at top and bottom games
but perugia and nepal will be our mark
marquee matchup and all of this fighting
what are they fighting for as we get a
a picture of the playing hall there uh
there you have you the prize money for
the rapid blitz event here in saint
louis uh from the total prize fund is
175 dollars with uh 40 000 going to the
eventual winner 13 second 25 for third
all the way down to seven for the last
place and gcd points also uh very much
at stake here with 13 if you win the
event outright and 12 if you have to
play a tie break
and a very
scant five minutes uh you get the two
second bonus very luxurious five minutes
very luxurious uh what's your favorite
blitz time control three plus one
honestly i prefer three plus two i think
yeah i think this
i don't mind i i just enjoy blitz these
days i very much like
like the the
the art of playing blitz but uh
for me personally i think three plus two
is um sort of
just the right just the right mix but i
understand that
uh
five plus two
allows perhaps a slightly more artistic
artistic expression of yourself
jumping christian your preferred uh uh
blitz
foreign five plus zero but that gets
wild very quickly um i won some games
by flagging my opponents in completely
losing positions and i have to say that
didn't feel
right so
i do prefer the increment three plus two
seems to be the sweet spot for me
yeah me too i remember in 1992 i had
gone to svettie stefan
and bobby fischer showed me
his new prototype of his chest clock and
was playing blitz throughout the
afternoon in the suite
and uh
eventually i came to the conclusion not
three plus one not three plus three not
five plus one the three plus two was the
best and uh afterwards in the evening uh
bobby said what was your preferred time
control i said three plus two he said me
too
so i felt i had done that's uh that's a
very good thing you you've done there
yes sir because i felt like we're just
sitting there you know slagging over the
choices of our employer and perhaps it's
very very not very wise if you if you're
in vogue if you involve the name of
fisher maybe we're on much safer ground
exactly
exactly
and there we go as uh the play is
underway and again this will be our
marquee matchup we don't mean
to ignore any of the other games of
course c45 d3 making an endurance yeah
people do like playing the sicilian to
the extent that they're gonna play it
with the white pieces as well reverse
night earth
yeah
pretty much uh
very very decent decent line
black generally equalizes in these types
of quiet night orbs and white will have
an extra tempo here compared to to those
positions so but if you don't cast along
then that tempo is a little bit less
relevant i guess a little bit surprised
by the move bishop e3 maybe b4 where the
idea of bishop b2 would be a little bit
more pressure on blood position it's a
it's a choice it's uh
it's very similar to those types of
knight of positions as well he goes with
a kind of an interesting mix of going
back
and returning to to the plans with b4
very much provoking the response that
that jan goes for a 504 is now obviously
very critical you can actually follow it
up with the immediate g5 but yan for now
yeah you stopping b5 does make sense
he'll play bishop six and now you
definitely want to start on your g5 g4
attacks on the king's side that's for
sure because strategically you don't
have that much time i also want to start
with rook take c6 exactly
which is why we're playing g5 here we're
not stopping yeah it's uh
rook c1 is going to be met by g from g4
and 6 is too late because h3 though how
do h5 will be meant by knight h2 yeah
right
and now after roxy one we will have to
make a decision because we i i don't
think we can allow rook takes
e6 maybe 26 or perhaps you can make an
argument for knight d4 but i don't like
that i think after knight g4 uh
bishop e5 knight e4 that or even knight
takes d4 bishop g4 and then put the
knight in f3 all of those things looks
very very unattractive for black
uh a key moment here
is absolutely playable that's for sure
yeah um
but it does make the games knight three
i think is what eliezer chose yeah c5 is
a c5 is a nice square to to aim that
piece towards we're not really that
worried about knight a4 bishop one i
don't think okay
uh so yeah uh rook 889 bishop c8
probably the follow-up
88 very heavily hinting at preparing
bishop c8 there
yeah a very kind of interesting double
position
knight takes a6 ideas
queen c2 also just queen b3 czech and
rook fd1 but i think you like it i think
institute judging by the the hand
movement there oh rookie one wow that's
a very deep that seems to that seems to
indicate he's looking at ideas from
pushing d3d4
and then potentially uh commentators
like to say interesting they don't know
what they're talking about but that deep
very deep is another way of putting it
i'm not actually criticizing this move
that much i think
uh because breaking things open in the
center here with d3d4 is extremely
attractive i don't think it works yet
but
uh but something to consider absolutely
jumping christian
if you had your choice right now as to
white or black who would you prefer i
would definitely prefer uh white
in this position it feels like black
doesn't have an active plan you would
love to play the move h5 and follow it
up with g4 the problem is that's always
going to be met by knight to h2 and your
king can get weak very very quickly so
it does feel like white has a nice grip
over the position right now rook to d1
is going to be followed by potentially
d4 in a lot of scenarios and you have
some pressure on the c file as well that
knight on c6 is going to be quite
immobile for a while exactly knight
takes a6 well
it is a pawn after all by the way i was
even considering a4 at some point
because you cannot take on b4 maybe
instead of this move queen to c2 a4 you
cannot take on b4 because i have queen
queen b3 check right
and just to try to kick the knight away
with b5 and has time become a factor the
players are definitely slowed down 3
minutes 20 seconds for nepo 3 minutes 50
seconds for ali reza so still within
range exactly both players and uh yeah i
saw something in in chat there briefly
and i was so shocked that i went to
check apparently this position if you
ask the machine is completely winning
for white not already slightly better
like it gives wise up like a full piece
advantage here which is completely
ridiculous when you think about it
there's there's 30 pieces on the board
right and there's only apart from knight
takes a6 there might not even be any
other immediate threads but yeah things
have just gone completely off the rails
there for for jan it's a kind of a
shocking shocking uh advantage
considering once again that material is
equal and not that i'm excited and i'm
not happy in fact playing the move
knight d4 but
would you have guessed that that's a
three
point advantage knight d4 i guess bishop
d4 and e5 might just be kind of
borderline winning i can definitely
imagine that then we take everything we
play bishop f3 with take on b7 things
start falling apart also you can do
something like knight xd4 bishop to g4
and the pawn on b7
i know like the more i look at this the
more i realize it's bad but i would
never give white i don't know more than
more than plus one here yeah absolutely
it's shocking just how much the machine
dislikes it but
the fact that white is better doesn't
really surprise me in the slightest yeah
it seems like jan
uh perhaps was a bit over optimistic
with the push on the king's side i think
he could have he could have played it
in a more conservative fashion somewhere
sedate now what's the point behind this
move rook to e1 followed by queen to c2
you were mentioning that rook to e1
should be probably connected with the
idea of d4 but then you play the move
queen to c2 and that doesn't connect
i think we can we can i think those
things actually kind of work together
because let's say we play 97 here which
maybe wouldn't have been such a stupid
move mm-hmm
yeah so you go 97 i think you lose to
g3d4 straight away because then d4 e4 e5
and we get the bishop c4 check wait a
minute a5 i think this is a very clear
sign of horrible dispersion so what if i
just take on a5 exactly
and then g4 and then then d4
yeah also also b5 i think will be kind
of winning as well like everything will
be close to winning here for white i
assume b5 i go knight d4 right yeah
once again bishop d4 ed for e5 i think
white is kind of winning in that
position i really do we trade everything
we got bishop three we win the pawn back
we have rooks on two open files very
strong bishop against the horrible
knight on b67 one on c7 yes no i think
it's it's actually busted yeah
so uh it's just very nice oh why the
wish right yes i just picked that the
engine it's 5.7 right now point seven
yeah
and we both we like b5 but we also
b4 takes a5
yes b5 was the best move b takes a5 is
only 4.2
only four points only four
because otherwise if he had captured
there was this move e5
uh e4 e5 pardon me which would have been
uh bastato
i have to say this is a very dominant
display by ali reza to start off the
blitz section if he manages to convert
this one right and he's playing against
a very useful and now we can choose we
can try calculating g5 but i think we're
kind of completely winning after g4 g5
so it's unnecessary just go d5 here and
go you just go d5 i think so as i've
been calculating the double captures
followed by knight d3 and queen c7 also
also extremely strong but i think after
d5 we win sort of more
like we win more i think yeah it's a
it's a question of you know it's a good
i like i like d5 very much d4d5
yeah let's say 97 93 yeah d5 i think you
have to play 94 just to confuse the
matters a little bit 97 93 you yeah this
is resignable
pretty much everything is resignable but
this is very resignable because you
can't give up on e5 you can't give up on
c7 like
your position just collapses just to
give you an update of what's to come
nakamura seems to be taking his revenge
against car one we probably should at
some point
start thinking about switching because
uh alireza is also firmly in control in
control on the clock and has a very very
go very clearly winning position but for
now we'll stick with this one absolutely
and i was just going to say i think
that a5 move was only made after like a
three year jun burned a lot of time
there he realized how bad his position
was so he thought okay let me try to at
least maybe complicate matters somewhat
but
yeah this is not good it doesn't feel
tricky
yeah you just take on e5 with something
even due take c6 i'm a business let me
through check there wow okay nice nicely
nicely noticed by earlier
you can't actually recapture on c6 with
whatever you want to recapture in six
with because queen b3 wins material so
he picks up the knight on c on b6 so
maybe queen takes c6 but anything wins
against that he goes bishop b6 but then
okay i'll take on b7 and then i'll take
everything else or
knight e5 yeah whatever you want to do
here it's just completely completely
lost yes it is it's just just a matter
of just a matter of taste how you choose
to
put this to bed by the way you have to
confess i would have taken on b7 there's
something like a pawn c4 i think oh
that actually would have given black one
active piece which one so he's trying to
go bishop to c5 that's one way and after
97 knight c4 now 97 94 97 97 i think
probably wins material quincy seven
chosen by yan but yeah i mean it's uh
it's really it really is a matter of a
matter of taste how you so how do we
finish i think six wins more material
yeah not six when we but if you don't
want to play any end games even
completely winning end games you can you
can i think it's gonna take yeah but why
not i mean you're you're pawns two puns
up everything yeah
there's not much here going on so why
not just play a completely winning end
game 15 second on his clock for nepo
still one of the great enemies
and compensation
yeah knight takes i think once again
just yes just so that we don't have to
play in game questions i mean which i
mean f i mean which knight are you going
to take f rook
that's almost
96 and queen b3 probably and then young
resigns yeah something like this yeah 96
rookie six queen b3 and uh that's good
bishop g4
i stopped at e5 as well but you're
absolutely right knight e6 and queen b3
yeah well that i stopped it yeah yeah
your choice your choice wins but yeah
like rookie 696 you know you're just
you're just down in exchange for it very
much but i love those absolute pins i
like what you wanted knight takes e6
yeah we've given like now the knight
only seven actually has a nice square
closer you know it's like it's like a
moral victory for black they have one
piece on a good square you've got an
active piece yeah like one good piece
which 94 now wins a bunch of more pieces
yeah yes that's a good time to get
interesting yeah okay well no
resignation no resignations
where would you like to take this
christian let's go to uh hikaru versus
uh caruana all right we're on it and
hikaru with the white pieces
has weathered much of the storm i think
he's still worse because he's a pawn
down but the the two bishops and the
active queen on c2 i think he has decent
drawing chances they're both very
absolutely close in time 20 seconds for
both i
i'm not even sure you the extra pawn is
an extra pawn but this doesn't seem very
uh very important yeah i would play
maybe g7 g5 at some point start getting
more pawns off the board bishop f5 and
putting it on an active square is also
kind of d3 perhaps yeah fabio you know
just says i my king is on h8 i'm a man
of culture it has to be close to close
to the reaction i also understand that
h5 i'm a bit surprised he did not
include bishop five somewhere but i
guess you always have the a4 b3 squares
okay g5 now fair enough i'm still
surprised that bishop is still on
disturbance i agree i would very much
like to have it on d3
and we could have gotten it to g3
wholeheartedly agreed yeah i'm a bit i'm
a bit surprised can why play the move f5
h3 g4 yeah i'm not sure i like what what
fabio is doing yeah
and this is a very strange thing
no he didn't try to yeah i think it's
time for us to maybe trade something
like i would be including gfgf at some
point but he clearly doesn't like it
in the meantime yeah one the one has one
he's gaming yeah okay so f5 here so at
some point you have to play a five night
we can go bishop six maybe yeah exactly
and dake's takes king e4 who's in swan
we go bishop g4 they have h4 i'm not
exactly i'm not sure this is a draw i
think we can maybe i'm not sure i like
bishop f6 i was just kind of curious
oh he goes g4 ah and hg king g3 king e5
yeah king three and he's just winning
yeah i was just
winning no but this is knight xg4 yeah
he's winning this is completely winning
yeah very nicely spotted that move king
g3 yeah i don't know i don't know why
our bishop stayed on d7 it really should
have left
versus by the way we've almost got a
whitewash at the moment as we have three
decisive uh games with uh white winning
all three
we are now on the game between sam
shanklin sam shanklin comes into today's
action no that's the moment
there used to be two pawns on the e file
one somehow got
misplaced and uh
now i think uh shaq is probably winning
because because this uh
probably gets carefully carefully
bricked by brick taken apart right so g5
at some point and this is interesting to
me because this is a line i
covered
from the greenhouse yeah it's a it's a
kind of a greenfield slash
anti-greenfield you get this this line
from a number of move orders and
either mvl mistrust my suggestions or he
unfamiliar with your course or is
unfamiliar with it
yeah and shanklin versus lanier has
finished in a draw
sam shanklin coming into today's round
in clear third place
sam as not noted as uh
one of the top rapid chess players in
the world no he's very you know he's
very good at rapid i think i think
really he actually actively dislikes
blitz my impression from last year was
that he is uh he doesn't really like
playing blitz all that much he is the
lowest rate yeah exactly i was going to
say yeah now we take and play e6 and we
put the bishop like on b2 if we can
oh
there was some hesitation
that's just completely lost yeah and
there you go he wanted to play bishop g7
i think he realized rook thinks you said
when i was winning on the spot exactly
by the way uh with that loss it does
mean that ali reza
isn't clear
first at the moment
but for hikaru who starts today's
competition in dead last
yeah the victory will kind of uh assuage
uh the the hurt that's uh he experienced
that last but with this victory i think
he catches at least fabiano if not more
than that right i think he catches up
with two we thought for sure right
because he just uh maybe linda some
content well there's another one who
lanier or jeffrey lanier yes yeah that
might be yes by the way four out of five
decisive games yeah in blitz i've never
thought that white had such a big
advantage and now we're seeing a
whitewash i think it's just round one i
think we will see plenty of plenty of
good results for for players playing
black as well shakri are on a bit of a
role here winning fourth in a row over
over the two formats so it doesn't
doesn't count exactly the same but uh
still it's his fourth victory in a row
if you know if you include yesterday you
raised everybody's curiosity you you do
a chessable course on the grunfeld
and you
saying that mvl shied away from your
suggestion yeah of sacrilege there's
there's a number of things you can do
here but what he's done is supposed to
be a forest draw and i believe it is a
forest draw okay
continue continuing value i mean we
don't have right but we can't really
cover it in so much detail but yeah in
this version of the bishop c5 there is
basically a choice you can do what mvl
did which is b6 and it's supposed to be
a draw or you can play bishop five which
i think makes a kind of a more forcing
draw if i remember my own notes
correctly after for example rook e1 i
think wind d3 is the point i see and
we're trying to relieve the pressure on
the f7 square by by trading some pieces
and
if i remember correctly this is this is
what you do here and it holds okay but
obviously this is also supposed to be a
somewhat passive but still a draw and
and we i think went for this very very
quickly
and then he played yeah he just gave up
the the exchange for the a pawn
instantly yeah and honestly somewhere
around here i thought this will be a
draw but as i mentioned one of the one
of the e pawns somehow got misplaced
yeah right not entirely sure how but
you misplaced you're almost thinking why
doesn't he play e6 e5 and just say okay
i'm passive but i've got i'll keep my
pawns and white went on to win
what is supposed to be drawn ending
christian uh any uh thing in this very
spectacular first round koch right i was
looking at this game between hikaru and
fabiano and try to understand how they
got to the position that we caught up
with them in the end of the broadcast uh
he started off hikaru that is with the
same thing that he started off in the
rapid section as well the c4 followed by
an early a3 idea a reverse sicilian like
this and fabiano responded with this
very aggressive setup e5 followed by the
move f5 now let's take a look at how the
players got to where they were when we
caught up with them this movie e4 didn't
make a strong impression on me because
it allows this move f3 and after that
after the center opens up and my bishop
gets a beautiful life with the potential
of e4 break it does seem like this
allows white to get the advantage
instead of that um probably he should
have kept the position as this kept the
tension in the center as it is with a
move such as bishop to d7 just continue
the development he played move e4 f3 and
we got to this position in which white
seemed like uh he's again getting a lot
of initiative due to the fact that the
bishop f3 is such a powerful piece and
your pieces especially this bishop on ca
the recon a8 are not playing a major
role in the position up to this point
take on c6 d5 and this was the critical
moment bishop to b to bishop to d7 queen
to d3 knight to e4 an interesting
sacrifice but what both players missed
right now was this beautiful tactic
knight to c7 it's very easy to um
not play this move because of the move
bishop to f5 a very powerful response
but if you do see this nice check bishop
takes g7 the idea being that as long as
the king is on g7 i can take on b8 and
if you do take on e4 i can take on e8
with a check follow it up by rook takes
c4 not only that i have the material
advantage but also your king is
extremely uh extremely weak you're going
to get checkmated in that situation both
of the players miss this and this
allowed black to get back into the game
fabiano to get back into the game i
think we caught up with the players
somewhere around this moment and yes of
course this was the critical mistake
bishop to f6 bishop takes f6 g4
h takes g4 king to g3 and now instead of
king to e5
king
exactly the bishop gets out not only
that okay you defend both pawns but i'm
going to be able to go bishop to d3 get
the king back to f6 and your knight is
not going to be able to defend both of
your pawns once you put the king on g4 i
will kick that king away with the move
bishop to e2 king to e7 or king to f7
were just simple draws after king to e5
actually this was a resignation move
right you take on g4 and you just simply
resign because of the fact that after
bishop takes g4 king take g4 king to f6
i still have a bullet left and that is
the move h3 you're forced to move to f7
or e5 the pawn on g5 falls and you lose
the game very very intriguing game
intriguing end game as well and as you
can see the boys are relaxing some of
them with their t some of them with
their water some of them with their is
that oj no
that is sparkling water by eronia
interesting
what do you do after big blitz uh round
well you stand around and uh chew the
fat and the standings after one let's
take a round of blitz uh peter uh
alireza is now in seoul uh in seoul lead
there up top winning winning his game
and uh mvl lost but he's still in clear
second because uh sam shanklin was not
able to
catch up to him by by winning his game
seven clear third and look at that
out of nowhere
languishing in dead last afternoon
he is now in clear in clear fourth on 10
out of 19 and then we have some people
on nine points linear is now on minus
two five minus three and yahikaro did
catch up to uh
so fabi uh on eight points
and uh
with round two of the
pairings uh coming up let's take a look
at our marquee matchup uh who do you
like i think of prior to the start of
the day we chose uh the clash between
fabi and mvl as our game to watch
because you know the temptation to watch
legends yeah is is quite strong but we
do have to you know partition the the
attention well put uh
we shower on the young man and uh
as a kind of a as a kind of a stand-in
we will take the game between napoli and
shankland absolutely sam beat uh
uh young in the uh rapid portion in a
very kind of a weird game where jan was
doing extremely well and then perhaps
overestimated his position a little bit
thinking that he can never really have
less than a draw right suddenly realize
that no now you don't have a job anymore
and went on to lose
but everything battle of the youth yeah
everything looks extremely exciting the
game between jeffrey and pharaoh is also
of course
and sam feeling good i mean the rapids
uh finishing third
in this illustrious field players uh in
the rapids must feel very very good and
can i mean again as uh christian pointed
out at the top of the show we've got uh
six out of the top 10 blitz players in
the world but sam isn't one of those uh
in fact he's
yeah yeah he's the lowest rated in the
blitz but uh he stands uh hoping uh to
uh improve his rating jump right in uh
christian uh the first game by nakamura
do you feel
that uh is
is going to get him back in the swing
it's definitely a good sign for him and
i have to say i was expecting him uh to
pull a much better performance in the
blitz section uh there's no coincidence
that he's also the best rated player on
the planet alongside levon aronian i
mean the guy is super good super fast he
takes decisions on a dime he's a good
player good blitz player unfortunately
for him i don't understand what happened
in the rapid section we know how good he
is in the rapid time controls as well
but right now he's definitely starting
uh to get back on track let's see how
this one goes for him absolutely
there's anastasia our colleague catching
up with the players uh shaq
enjoying his coffee slash t we're not
too sure
throwing a big smile as by the way
shakriar
if you think of the rapid chess as being
worth two points seven out of seven
he's in the middle of a role there uh
for sure and uh it was very nice to uh
to listen to him talk yesterday when he
said that i mean it's rapid you know
streaks happen you can have bad days but
i i just approached it as i always
approach it let's just try to play
interesting chess let's try to enjoy
chess and i think you know with him it's
clearly not a pose right for him i think
the enjoyment the enjoyment of the game
still plays a major major part of why he
continues you know playing chess while
he continues being a chess professional
and when it flows for him it's just a
joy to behold and
yesterday was a very prime example of
that speaking of a joy to behold and the
opposite thereof uh anastasia posting on
the social media
uh a clip yesterday uh at the end of
round nine
fabi defeated
hikaru
nakamura there was a huge storm going on
in saint louis and hikaru leaves the
plane off really walks into a tree
he was furious yeah he was not impressed
with himself because he started
the day really well and exactly and then
that that happened yeah yeah and this is
the young american jeffrey shong yeah
they're waiting for round two
uh this is arguably in in in these sort
of long blitz days that they haven't run
to them these kind of ten minute breaks
between games arguably sort of the most
annoying thing about the entire
precision right then then your nerves
start to play and you start to think
thinking what should i be preparing and
you shouldn't be thinking about your
preparation at this point
it also very much interrupts your flow
yes and and blitz is you know
more than i guess anything else in chess
bliss is very much a game of flow
exactly
if if you're playing well you really
don't want anything to get to get in the
way of you maintaining this feeling of
you know
being in control of your actions being
you know trusting your decisions and so
on by the way uh
i
i
i need to ask you how how do you like
blitz yourself and uh did you win a
blitz
i was one i was one move away from a
world blitz title one one move away
your flag fell in a way
it's a very typical story for me i
played uh
i think it was 2006 i played a tie break
for the title an armageddon game against
my good friend sasha grishouk
uh and i basically like i played the
sicilian and i lost my d6 pawn by move
10 somehow contrived to just lose
straight up lose the central point and
then i saved the game already
and i also have like three 40 seconds
against and i draw and the draw gives me
the draw gives me gives me the title
and then there is a position i'm i'm
down the road but i have very far
progress pawns
and you just need to you know continue
pushing and i have a very very clear-cut
choice which every sane person makes in
that position and then i realized that
there is a way to maybe make a draw by
being more artistic you know instead of
actually capturing his last pawn with my
king you can go in a different direction
with your king and then push the pawns
away
and that actually loses
and that was the closest i ever got to
uh to the world title yeah snatching
defeat from the jaws of absolutely yeah
it still stings yeah all of those over
there were 15 18 years later and by the
way because you mentioned sasha grisha i
mean
yeah
but i suspect that you played a lot of
blitz with him over the years yeah for
sure yeah nice and yasser by the way
you're also the
dutch bliss champion aren't you the what
oh
yeah unfortunately and it was really
really sad uh my whole career i loved to
play blitz i mean it was just it was
what we did in seattle and
what we did at
open tournaments here in the united
states whenever there was like a
free time you you played some blitz but
there was never really a world blitz
championship and st john in canada they
tried it and it was well received the
public loved it michael tall won it by
the way uh but they didn't have it like
they do today yeah you know and it's
it's a famous church in which uh gary
kasparov uh stalemated kiril giorgi
correct with the queen and the bishop
that's right against an empty king yeah
that that's right it was a a famous
diagram
also famous story where karil checkmates
uh oh pardon me kirill captures
vaganyan's king but vaganyan hadn't
pressed the clock and they had they they
did a replay where vaganyan realizes
that his king's in check stops his hand
and kiro captures the king
and so they had to continue the game it
was wonderful by the way though it was a
great world championship uh
unfortunately
they didn't have enough and pity pity
yeah but now it's very much part of the
calendar and i think for a lot of people
it's the highlight of the year magnus
rather than blitz yet so you know even
after playing with nepo a very very uh
difficult match when i think it was at
poland yes exactly
to play in the rapids and the blitzes
our marquee matchup
about to be underway
what can you tell us about uh what's hap
gonna happen in this game
oh okay let's wait and see they're gonna
shake hands
and then the horsey will make a sarty i
think once again he's trying to
lure mvl into some sort of a newfound
maybe
e4 let's go
no i mean i knew i knew it wasn't
happening but still like the double fee
it's a it's a fun idea too
so now do you play d4 or do you go
bishop g2 and allow e5 d4 yeah d4 and uh
yeah this is a kind of a weird one but
uh mvl i don't think we'll be extremely
unhappy because exactly
he will have some idea about this we've
all encountered this once or twice in
our lives for sure for sure
i always thought it was interesting that
he allows a4 i probably would have would
have been tempted to to not allow this
to happen exactly
and now black has an option of taking
everything off the a file or you can
also just ignore it and play something
like knight c6 and uh
bd7 or bishop
as we see bishop five and just continue
annoying white with that pawn on a4
because like he would like to perhaps
play knight c3 yeah this is another
movie i was wondering about that but
when
279394
i guess is the plan there by mbl
absolutely knight h4 there knight h4
knight takes c3 bishop takes b7 is
hanging it's kind of annoying me i'm not
sure this has been
we haven't takes a4 in the end i think
94 does work we'll see yeah
does go for it and the line we're
discussing is 94 because i think five
people will probably stop here for a
second knight h4
we take on c3
yeah uh bishop takes c3 bishop h3 is the
point i'm pretty sure right
uh why are we doing it with arrows uh or
just
yeah just to show well i don't want to
make an analysis because then
i'll have to refresh the board because
of the uh
the my analysis becomes the first line
of fair enough so knight takes e4 bishop
takes knight h4 you are
immediately knight right now h4 right
now where the knights get traded bishop
h3 and i thought this would be seven was
strong yeah i thought there should be
seven was strong but you have rook takes
a four there in the end
so you're saying bishop h3 okay but can
you take on b7 right now it should be
seven okay four um
because we did
to the idea of c6 knight d5 he played
knight d5
well knight h4 is still some sort of a
threat you cannot take on a4 because of
knight takes e7
so you have to kick that knight away but
how do you do it because c6 right g5 is
a clever
i've missed it completely and maybe so
did mvl because yeah your your choices
are very limited you can't you can't
pick up the ball on a4 you can't play
bishop h3 for all the same reasons both
e7 and c7 will be hanging and knight h4
is a major threat so knight to f6
actually i think this is a good reaction
i think he kind of had to do that
because yeah the desirable c6 also
allows knight to b6 but what about
knight h4 now
um i think i still ah yeah and if you go
[ __ ] page three maybe i can take on
these seven yeah i think we're taking
seven i'm pretty sure we're taking only
seven so you take only seven we go king
h8 then 95 back yeah knight d5 remember
i've already clipped one pawn and i've
clipped the second pawn with the e7 as
well so they repeated once
uh looks like uh it went back to c3 and
back to e4
i see
i kind of like that version for white
with knight yeah i'm surprised i'm
surprised he didn't just play knight h4
there
so he's probably considering
knight to h4 in this position right now
try to calculate the variations after
knight c3 bishop h3
yeah because 95 did look like a very
very smart choice it did i like it much
but i like it much better than anything
else here frankly as far as i can tell
anything else is
is really not as good yeah and by the
way knight d5 knight f6 queen b3 just
saying that as well go ahead just as
well do something i mean although
there's a wide choice i think 95 queen
takes a four might be fine there can be
seven
i'm not going to take on b7 i play rook
c1 or something of that nature just
that's not going to be very try to say
yeah once again i think compared to 99
five now that's a surprising choice can
i go c6 right truly and i think he wants
to go back and he says the pawn only 4
will be
much
safer much safer yeah it's an
interesting choice but not the one i
would have gone through no no if just
doesn't feel like it takes takes takes
c5 for instance i think is very very
attractive here i think he's going for
it yeah takes days bishop before
followed by c5 could also be made made
an argument for but i think just going
to treatment of takes and bishop e4 i've
just seen that so often these days it
almost goes hand in glove but i think
with the cap i think c5 immediately is
also just perfectly fine because we we
do have we still have bishop h3 as a
response to knight h4 a4 is now hanging
but maybe that's what i have to do right
now knight h4
and after a beast page three just
exchange that go rook to b1 try to put
some pressure on ab7
isn't uh the the diagonal pin knight c6
an issue though christian it might be
i'm going to defend that e3
and just try to play between the seven
back i don't think it's bad for black
no by the way we do have queen b3 on the
board i'm just going to refresh
my board sorry that i have to do that
but that's just the way these
uh programs work
defending c3 by the way uh introducing
yeah the threat so what's the problem
i think we can take on a4
in many of these positions you can
actually take on e4 invite queen takes
b7 and play something like knight c6 or
knight g7 with the idea of rook fb8
queen takes yeah quintex yeah
i don't like rook takes because no i
don't know this combobulates my pieces a
little bit too much but queen takes
seems to be fine unless maybe no knight
h4 will take one d4 yeah we can take on
d4 for sure so yeah i think unveil is
likely to if you take on queen a4 i can
take on c5 interestingly enough yes
maybe this is for queen v3 and d3 that's
why he's gone knight he's got knight a6
with the intention i guess of taking on
d4 and putting the knight on c5 which
would be a very very beautiful piece if
it lands there yeah that would be a
handsome
handsome horsey
e3 yeah that makes sense stopping that
plan that we're discussing because of
course white would very much like to
recapture with the pawn not with any of
the pieces this is now the time for
bishop e4 we played it yes do i have
knight e5 and
a 5g4 yeah
if i might take on a5 i take on g4 right
twice on d4 that's right that's quite a
few pawns that's true and knight c5 is
still coming on board exactly
yeah
well but on the other hand i feel that
white has to be very careful because
he could easily slip into uh oh
absolutely with these double the a pawns
into a worst
end game knight h i like this move
knight h4
because that knight is definitely
redirecting uh itself towards the d5
square yeah we will of course recapture
with the knight and then perhaps 9495
knight b6 is
going to be on the menu
yeah this is
i'm not sure knight a6 was best uh isn't
there a a problem on the c4 square i can
take on d4 yeah maybe i'll take it back
with the bishop
now
this knight on g2 is also coming through
e3
e3 if you want to do that i'll wait for
the knight to get to f4 good point we go
rook fc yeah yeah
as a prelude to capture very very nice
and yeah walk he played knight of four
very quickly so i guess he has 95 there
right if we play 26 here i think 95 is
quite annoying which is why once again
mbl also recognizing the spanzer temple
on e6 exactly but queen c6 very much
knowledgeable six is now a threat yes
so we actually just go back knight g2
knight
it's a difficult difficult thing but
maybe we don't yeah i think i would be
inclined to play a move like bishop b2
just to make the move rook c one
if you close the b file i will actually
consider just playing on the knight b8
and taking on a4 with the rook if you if
you close down your b file and you can
no longer attack the b7 pawn he has
played rook c1 inviting bishop h6 by the
way yeah we have bishop d2 there so he's
basically saying that after screen c6
i'm going to go d5 and i call that
actually queen take c4 i think we
exchange everything and then the e6 bond
hangs at
well you mentioned knight b8
peter what yeah how do you like them
apples still very much exists yeah give
me this pawn on a plate
played by mvl yeah
by the way and we are enjoying a an
almost 40 seconds advantage on the clock
uh how conscious are you of the clock uh
when you're playing blitz i think
somewhere around that moment when you're
down to like a minute and a half to a
minute you have to start paying
attention you can you can sort of you
glance after yeah yeah you can sort of
ignore it you can afford to ignore it
until until that moment but
once you get to that vicinity you have
to be very very conscious of and now he
has to go d5 yeah
you'll try to pull the prize take on e6
and now the question is do we play c5
whether we go rook f1 and we don't
really rush with anything c5 d5 yeah
it's very important that we we as white
we got to soften the structure in the
center here otherwise we would be maybe
just straight up worse yeah very bad by
the way there were some funny lines with
c5 d5 queen b6 zero kc c6
maybe that would have been interesting
in the meantime i think hikaru is
completely winning against levon we
don't need to go there but
that's
yeah that's a really really shocking
shocking in a way that like it's a
like a lot happened in that game but i
think icarus is completely winning by
the way bishop h6 comes at a time where
there is no bishop to d2
uh
nobody wants to see that structure of
bishop takes f4 g takes f4 peter no this
is a real challenge and also 25 seconds
yeah i think this was missed and i think
this is now a problem for uh for fabi
because he needs to find a way to kind
of bail out
so
yeah he just allows gf i think he had no
no real choice to
i also couldn't find anything that
wasn't allowing gf
but
you know this is equal material in this
structure
horrifying structure
by the structure they're really really
not good for for phobia at all rook
comes to f5 very nicely yeah rook g4
there are still weaknesses on e6 and d6
which do provide white with
uh
some hopes otherwise like if black had a
slightly more solid structure you just
you just write this off if you don't
have that and by the way hakaru is
up to his billing christian as one of
the best blitzers in the world as he
goes two out of two absolutely and uh
this was a very important direct
encounter because right now he's
building up some rating advantage over
levon as well
yeah and uh
in sort of a continuation what was
happening in the rapid uh jan who had a
very very safe catalan game against sam
shankland seems to have just blundered
the full piece what
and is now very likely to lose with the
white pieces too to sam yet again yes
wow
i'm more than surprised by the move rook
on f5 to f6 somehow i was expecting the
other rook to
to go to f6 and the queen go to f7 the
uh alekhine's gun if you will
queen to e2 defending the pawn on c4
reinforcing the threat of rook takes d6
how do you defend against that
rook to eighth just simple like that
whoa whoa whoa whoa i think so yeah we
we really don't want to trade any of
those horrible horrible weaknesses nf7
that's a very concrete move but i think
we can take on the six yeah this is
that this will be a draw now queen takes
e6 yeah this is going to be an
unpleasant rook ending but you don't
lose it whoa
whoa whoa
that's an excellent why would you play
that oh queen takes e6 check he's
actually improved the end yeah by oh
yeah okay so
was just simply brilliant because uh
yeah and nvl actually going into a worst
rook ending now but i mean he will not
lose it but it's a worse end game
rook a4 okay three i think they won't
even play this out honestly there's just
zero chance to to win this well the move
rook b2 is an indication that
well i mean there's no risk for white he
might as well but he's not winning this
position no i was thinking rook takes h7
and would have been the draw off or yeah
exactly exactly yeah
and interestingly alireza looked like he
was completely winning but in the end
jeffrey managed to hold what looked like
a very very risky position and now uh
pardon me favi uh thinks twice about
maybe making a king walk all the way to
the queen side
not too sure about the move h5 there
it's fine yeah it's fine
yeah the issue is that like there's just
no progress to be made exactly yeah i
think i think there will just shaken
somewhere here
yeah
very very nice uh christian so we have
this conversion this is actually an
interesting conversion there
in the game because like it
you assume it's winning but
it's actually not that easily winning at
all because this setup with the three
against four on one side okay is kind of
shockingly tricky maybe even a classical
game because there's only a weakness on
f2 right so we have to get to f2
something yeah and it's interesting that
he continues trading like i wouldn't
have traded there i would have tried
preserving my structure as much just on
the second rank and bishop c3 bishop e1
what about yeah it takes h5 oh sorry uh
there's no knight no i mean well i i'm
way behind i'm on a different game
altogether yeah shakhriar is on five out
of five in the meantime three two one my
goodness three two one yeah and uh sam
found a way to ask a different question
he's just sacrificed the bishop but ke2
is a move right now oh no can you see i
mean i guess the h pawn i think you lose
so you have to kind of close your eyes
and take on g3 but that looks horrible
king of three yeah he's done it
uh ah rookie five is clever yeah rookie
five is very clever king no this is a
draw now i haven't assumed right rook h5
you don't you don't lose this no
one second on the wall
yeah this this is now a very easy draw
and just swing over to a5 and start
giving checks
it's a draw even without the uh the the
digipond i get the feeling that this is
a draw regardless but yeah this is just
a very very
comfortable draw for for jan so yeah but
i was about to say yeah it's uh
it was
well but he just yes this is a very
comfortable drawer so he's just not
interested very nice
whoo
yeah this is a five-fold now a five-fold
repetition so the young saves this one
uh seems a bit dejected with i guess the
quality of his own players i i know i'm
drawn i know him well no he lost the
first one no i'm just looking at the
round two uh one win with the black
pieces by shaq by the way
and one win by the white pieces and
a draw so absolutely
two decisive games after we started with
four but it just felt like every game
including this one that we just followed
could have easily been decisive uh
christian over to you what caught your
eye in this melee well you guys were
talking about this game between jeffrey
shang and uh ali reza in which jeffrey
actually survived miraculously this was
the key position after bishop takes e4
g takes f3 king to h1 and this at this
point hit go on e4 and unfortunately
after taking on g6 you don't have a
clear way of defending the pawn on e4
and unfortunately for you are unable to
get the pawn on h3 and deliver the
checkmate if you try to do that which he
did with the move queen to f5 i just
simply go king to h2 i don't take on e4
of course this would be just checkmating
a couple of moves take and queen to g2
but again after king to h2 you still
have this big weakness on e4 and if you
lose that you're actually going to be
losing with the black pieces because the
pawn on f3 is going to hang as well big
big moment and after king to h1 what he
should have done was once again focus
his attention on the pawn on h3 and
salvage the knight keep the knight in
the position because that's going to be
a piece that will help your queen to
deliver the checkmate queen to h4 or
queen to h6 both of them are working
create an immediate attack on the pawn
on h3 and after a bishop takes f3 you
have to take on f3 otherwise you get
checkmated you can take on h3 king to g1
once again don't take on f3 keep the
knight in the position play a move such
as knight to f4 and after that it does
seem like white has enough resources to
defend the problem is this bishport f3
is kind of immobile if you play bishop
to h1 then i have this check on g4 and
what i'm going to do as black in the
position is get another uh rook into
play rook to f7 or rook to f8 followed
by rook to f5 or rook to f6 if you do
take on e6 and then i'm going to find my
way on the g file that's going to be
delivering a checkmate tremendous
consequences after the route comes into
play he did not do that and jeffrey was
able to force uh the draw and the the
other one that you guys were mentioning
was i believe this game between hikari
the opening there was
just insane insane b3 bishop two a b5
f6 it does seem like white is actually
losing a tempo but
it does come with some consequences
in the center specifically and if black
doesn't manage to develop his pieces on
the king side and hide the king in time
which he didn't because he got greedy as
we will see in just a second he will be
in trouble levon there is bishop takes
the four knight xd4 queen takes d4
castle
knight to h3 bishop two a3 you wanna
take my uh rook take it please take the
right take it which he did unfortunately
this was a mistake for him what he was
supposed to do though it's not easy uh
from a practical perspective is to play
the move a bishop to f5 and then just
simply continue your development with
the move king to f7 bring the rooks into
play and just play that position he got
greedy he took on a1 and unfortunately
for him after bishop takes c6 queen to a
h5 everything comes with tempo and we
get this material in balance
two rooks for the queen the problem is
whenever we see this material imbalance
in the position is very important for
the side with the queen that the queen
has targets and that it has targets
related to a weak king and this is
exactly what we see in the position
that's the target the king on the e8 the
pawn on c6 a big target as well and
there's no coordination between your
pieces either these rooks are still far
away from getting back into play the
knight on h6 not greatly placed it's
just not looking good for black and
white went on and won a smooth game a
very very important victory for hikaru
and right now two out of two he's
climbing back into the standings
so this is this is the standings after
two rounds of blitz with alireza a point
and a half could have been two out of
two but a point and a half out of two
enough for a full point lead over mbl
shaq is now in amazing tied for third
with with sam uh jan and uh jeffrey are
on uh that's actually minus one right
that's 20 games played sorry so to speak
yeah right
so uh only four people above 50 and
every the rest below 50 right now with a
surging hikaru nakamura now tell us
about cubitique yeah what's our special
for today for today we are offering you
this uh grandchild story t-shirt uh a
way to celebrate the granchester with a
limited edition official 2022 t-shirt
that features all of the stops along the
tour on the back of the shirt as you can
see there
and the saint louis chess club chess
club logo on the right sleeve
are available as is uh everything else
that we offer you on the show at
cubitique
stl.com
wonderful to take a look
and we're just going to take our first
short break of the day we'll see you on
the other side
[Music]
hey st louis the ascension charity
classic presented by emerson is back
this september don't miss the excitement
when the pga tour champions best compete
again all for charity september 9th
through the 11th at norwood hills
country club pro-am spots hospitality
packages vip tickets and more available
now at ascensioncharityclassic.com
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
here we come
hello and welcome back to round three of
the blitz the first round robin of the
blitz uh as you can see the rest is
still leading a full point ahead of his
uh compatriot maximum shiela grab
shahriar now tied for third with sam
shanklin the real story peter this man
check he's on a roll five out of five or
eight out of eight if you if you will
exactly i like the eight out of eight by
the way it sounds more impressive and my
pick hikaru nakamura showing life
absolutely yeah he won he won two out to
two games so far very very nicely beat
his uh
uh you know in as much as there are
grudge matches in this tournament yes
exactly hikaru against levon potentially
is one and so he will be very happy with
beating levon in this fashion exactly
and our parents for this the round three
of our blitz first day of blitz yeah and
this is the game i think that you have
to pick there our leader uh our yeah
glorious leader alireza furuja playing
uh against hikaru who is still only tied
for seven but he's clearly uh you know
came to play to today uh two out of two
clearly on a much better
uh we'll have maybe the
shack versus nepo as a backup game that
sounds that sounds like a good backup
yeah
two days ago was in clear last no
victories three losses is now tied for
third with sam uh
really making a run for it only a point
and a half bit behind alireza absolutely
predictions what are we going to do a c
from ferruja in this game
um knight f3 e4 well e4
he was very successful with the english
against nepo that is true that could be
that could be something c4 that he chose
for this tournament in general he might
just stick with it
but the problem is that hikaru also
played the same thing c483
fabiano twice so he definitely knows the
nuances of that variation
sunflowers versus pineapples i don't
know
i don't think those are sunflowers you
don't think they're sunflowers i don't
think so they might be chrysanthemums
yeah
they they do look like sunflowers but
they're a bit smaller i think some of
them are sunflowers but not all of them
i get the feeling that the one sort of
immediately below the neck that's a that
i know that's actually than the the
dandelion no
right uh yeah
dandelions yeah i'm a huge botanical
expert here well done
checking in
i recognize the pineapples i'm part with
myself about that peter i'm gonna i'm
not gonna go any further
i'm not going to continue you know
bringing shame to our family because
exactly oh they would actually know
every single flower on that shirt here
we go
exactly what i would call a hearty hand
clasp more like a touching uh with the
hands mm-hmm there so we see the birds
having said that white might have gotten
somewhere in this tournament even uh mvl
uh
won that game against uh
sam shankund i believe right um but of
all of the players in this event i think
one of the players who has the most
experience on both the white and black
side of this variation has to be hikaru
i seem to for some reason
seen a lot of his games
yeah i'm very surprised by this
i think it's a mark of respect i think
alireza he probably also has a kind of a
small idea to get maybe a little bit of
something a little bit of a bite but you
never get more than just a tiny tiny
bite in these types of structures right
and i think that he does this being a
point ahead of the field
is is definitely a nod towards
recognizing he's playing one of the
absolute best players uh blizz players
uh all in the world so yeah he is just
respect yeah is that what this is
christian just a respectful approach by
the young phenom i think so uh he also
played this with the black pieces and
i'm trying to remember
when i think it was in one of the grand
chess tours perhaps in a zagreb he
played this variation and he was
actually on the back foot for the whole
game so maybe he learned something from
uh those games important not to blunder
the c7 pawn right now exactly he would
like to play d5 but i think currently
should be completely unpleasable because
of bishop take c7 yeah i wonder if we
can actually afford to play g6 to play
g5 next move exactly because i think the
pawn belongs on d5 you don't want to
play g6 exactly 94 knight d2 to e4 would
be white's
preferred sorry developer h6 knight d2
d5 and yeah that looks in time uh yeah
and i think generally they play g6 not
h6 because you want them to have the g7
square for the knight in some cases
also i think if you play the move h6
after bishop d3 d5 i still have bishop
take c7 and then the rook on eight is
hanging yeah that is a very cute little
line there so perhaps g6 is the right
movement but he does go with d6 which is
interesting 92 and now
you're not in time to cover e4 yeah this
is a bit awkward now you might have to
play something like bishop 694 bishop b7
is obviously g7 knight e4 b7 i assume
you are not allowing well there you go
there white got the nibble yeah we
definitely get uh
e7 queen d2 followed by rookie one and
white has the more active pieces
whether he can use that to create a
material advantage or not that's a
different question but uh something
something something
yeah something something something is
exactly what i wanted to say right
but as far as a backup because this game
might go
into very very quiet channels quickly
anything caught your eye christian
well i'm trying i'm actually
continuing yeah right now uh
the game between uh shah and nepo is
once again the the berlin of one d4 and
uh we don't want to look at that no i
don't think i don't want it even though
shaq has gotten some amazing positions
out of that opening
but yeah i'm expecting jan to actually
know what he's doing for you know
because
shaq is doing exactly what he did
against against jeffrey there it's a
straight repetition of his line against
jeffrey and if young also doesn't
equalize in the same line it really
starts becoming suspicious
there's nothing extraordinary happening
in any of the games so we can stay with
this one
okay it's interesting that knight e4 has
not been played i'd rather choose bishop
d3 instead allowing bishop g5
specifically because it is allowing
bishop g5 exactly and he trades very
very very much favored black
particularly this trade i think it's
just still it just makes black's life so
much easier i thought maybe he wants
queen e4 but if you play queen e4 here i
think i can take on f4 and specifically
play queen h4 which i think is quite
clever there
uh
between h4 is yeah otherwise the knight
on f5 gets hit and maybe white
preserves some pressure but queen h4 i
think solves most if not
hang on there's queen of three there in
the end maybe this does work so you're
sorry you're thinking queen e4 yes trade
on f4
and meet a queen
attack queen h4 with just dropping the
queen back hitting b7 hitting f5 yeah
makes a lot of sense
and uh queen e4 coming on the board yes
it did i believe so from our
uh webcam there
yeah i think i think nothing else made
any sense whatsoever i think if you
don't play this move if you just allow
black comfortably to trade on their own
terms right you're just not going to
have anything at all so this was the
only way to at least you know well
pretend you have something
versus caruana is developing nicely if
you guys want to take a quick look at
that
uh
pardon me it was lavon versus fabi just
take a quick glance
yeah this one is this one is reasonable
that's uh blowing up and especially i
can see i think c5 is being planned yeah
absolutely after knight f6 which i think
you play kind of automatically i think
the plan is maybe even the immediate c4
c5 exactly xc5 bit xc5 put the knight on
d6 and try to enjoy life
for sure uh that would be is there a way
to stop the knight coming to d6
not that i can see not immediately at
least i mean if you have to make an ugly
ugly move like he's got rook c6 instead
of knight f6 so he is clearly also not
enjoying the
the
thought of that but now you have to uh
contend with the ideas of d5 as well
yeah
also also i don't quite understand why
that stops c5 if we're
honest with ourselves
i'm not sure i'm not sure if we've done
a particularly good job of stopping c5
so yeah only because uh christian's d4
d5 starts to be attractive i think he
might i actually
do
pause to consider it
yeah and also and also d5 immediately is
uh is what i i actually didn't want to
do that at all because i feel like
suddenly there are squares for the black
pieces but yeah i can understand just
sort of trying to win or maybe i don't
get a large advantage uh immediately
here by playing against the weakness on
d6 well especially because nikon is on
g5 right but we've revived the bishop on
b7 we gave the knight on g7 both the e5
and the c5 square potentially if you if
you're intending to take on a5 later
i i'm not i'm not a fan i i think i
would have preferred both c5 and or a33
even keeping everything yeah even a3 i
kind of much prefer to this the only
reason i find myself drawn to white's
choice
is because i see this knight takes d6
and this knight f5 and i just think the
knight is just well let's let's continue
the line first yeah let's say 8 takes
before exactly knight takes d6 knight a4
knight a4 yeah we've given black we've
given black so many squares which were
never going to become available
man you are just not uh not a4 hasn't
been played yet but i think it will be
that's such an important and it has been
placed right now yeah and i want to show
you a trade secret please right now you
can right click on the move knight a4
right click left click run on in
annotation
and the notation oh yeah and go promote
okay and go promote variation yes and it
will magically
become the main line so you don't have
to switch between games i didn't know
that
and this is why i was attracted the
whole d5 because the queen's come
yeah well i'm just saying uh what i've
been doing this for a dozen years
maybe not with the leachates
i understand i mean it's still an
enjoyable position for white probably
but it feels like black should be able
to survive like rookie eight yeah
followed by bishop
once you get your knight into c3 i'm not
really enjoying it i don't think i don't
think we've done this right i think this
one is closing in on being just a simple
draw i think we should probably go back
to the ali reza versus sicario game
because okay ali reza is definitely
getting something yeah in the meantime
jeffrey somehow is a queen up against
sam say what a queen up yeah aquina just
briefly yeah for some reason white
appears to have lost yeah the queen
actually got captured on g3 if we go
like five moves back
same play bishop p2 and move 20
here yeah and
suddenly yeah yeah yeah and then but
just just yeah let's stop with the stop
with the jumping let's go back to the
game of our of our leader okay no yeah
and this one
can we take on g6 i would like to but
it's probably just perpetual right this
is where we left it but he does take on
g6 yeah
and this is ooh bishop takes g6 yeah all
of it's all of it on the board king f8
so but it feels like dupont it feels
like you have you do have to give a
perpetual because if you allow bishop
five your checks might run out and the
knight on g2 really doesn't look like an
attacking so let's go g4 ah g4 is clever
yeah but i think okay he'll repeat once
because he can always repeat yeah maybe
he can't repeat
yeah well i mean you you always can
repeat but you cannot play g4 anymore
maybe that's the point yeah i mean h7 is
still i mean
h7h8 is a very comfortable perpetual but
right you might not have the option of
returning to that idea of playing gt2 g4
so it seems like maybe the game will now
end in the draw
yeah there we go he also is on 30
seconds against a minute and a half so
it's an understandable decision by
by the young iranian a frenchman
yeah very good and christian where would
you uh
mvl versus dominguez is definitely a
very interesting one it seems like mvl
might be piling on a nice advantage
um yeah that was a very strange
structure from from the get-go uh and
white is now yeah white is very much in
control for sure yeah c6 is a it's
actually a choice because you could make
an argument for g5 d6 not really like
putting the pawn on the on the square
where it's very nicely controlled and
getting knight to c6 yeah to support the
promotion but
rook c8 rook g6 is also very solid the
e5 is going to hang
and it's not easy to see how black
solves this but i think rook c8 is a
good move knight maybe might take c5
immediately but exactly
bishop c7 knight g4 or somewhere yeah
knight takes e5 bishop c7 knight c4 and
then i can get the same position with my
rook on d7 for some reason my my eye was
somehow solely drawn to the move rook v6
here which i think is
an
an accuracy because of the king of fade
your pieces get a bit stuck
yeah okay but if i take one e5 which he
did can i just try to create something
with my kinking g7
just try to get out
yeah i think you should yeah and this is
why i was
this pawn six it looks beautiful but
it's sort of precariously placed and
because we're after all we're playing an
end game with the knight against bishop
we really don't want to be
someone can play rook to d6
and now bishop c7 you have the check
yeah stopping stopping the king from
reaching the f6 square at least
comfortably is a good choice yeah
also importantly uh
linear is on 10 seconds as as per usual
that's very usual bishop c7 rook d7
check on the board
king f6 we can win the h7 pawn but maybe
we have more and yeah mbl says not
interested i want to keep complete
control goes knight c4 and linear uses
this
time to at least put the pawn
on h5 away from immediate danger
we're still not winning immediately with
it right
yeah i was i was wondering if you uh uh
prefer oh he went 96 i was a little bit
afraid
about these rocks
g6 is weak i think he's not convinced
about this well i think it's a good
choice i think it's a good choice
because the king has not created fast
the king can not really uh approach our
setup because the king side is too weak
now we go rook g6 or h6
i think i think this is quite good
that's too many points yeah and yeah
lanier recognizes he has to stop the
king from reaching like uh c4
comfortably and
but how is is this i go king d6 okay
i go c7 maybe she's seven yeah she's
seven wins on the spot and she shoots ah
rooks
that's a classy one that is classy
rugby three check king g4 even even the
pawn ending after before rook c4 is
completely winning because we will have
it's actually getting flagged yeah and
mbl wins are very important for our race
for first absolutely yeah another
technical task between aronian versus
fabiano very very similar actually to
that position we were discussing in the
uh
uh
when you publish shanklin game with
three against two on one side but i
think the knight is much better than the
bishop in this context because it can it
can attack pawns on that on any kind of
yeah they're very very short on time so
don't blunder don't undermate yeah very
important but yeah
f3 now has fallen yeah this is now very
very technical for easy g5 just take on
g5 yeah that's awesome
93 was made in one which was not spotted
yeah that was that was a good move
made ends the game guys
yeah but this also ends the game this is
not really a problem
true but uh yeah i mean you you it's
kind of you're advised to play knight
three right i'm not i'm not suggesting
it's not a good idea to actually
yeah
win the rook after king h5 yeah yes mvl
recognizes that this loses and and
resigns yeah
yeah
oh that was that was the only sorry that
wasn't yeah that was and let's jump at a
game of sam shanklin jeffrey with a very
similar end game to that one
and yeah this one this one is reasonably
comfortably winning a king of three
doesn't create you can start with knight
g5 g5 and then we take we go king g4 or
e4 yeah kingifor is actually much more
cultured for sure yeah
yeah resigns yeah
jeff jeffrey seems to have uh sam's
number in this tournament that's two out
of two for human both with black yep
and let's go to the game uh the the
remaining game of shakriar yeah
what john actually made a game out of
this he will now be a pawn up he
shouldn't really win anyway it's too uh
it's too little but
yeah bishop
d3
wait a minute wait a minute that's it
you still have a6 to get the knight out
yeah but
that was not uh that takes e3
i think he's gonna take taken in bishop
he's playing for a win now yeah knight
for check is on tap very understandable
maybe you can make a draw like this yeah
that would have been but he goes he goes
it's already extremely difficult to make
a draw yeah i think
i think you're struggling here i think
you're struggling here for sure well
i'll take on b5 yeah take on b5 actually
yeah or or f5 yeah one of those one of
those two and take
now it takes b five now bishop yeah i
would have taken on b5 first actually
right right right five bishops is seven
yeah that doesn't do very much whoa whoa
what was that whoa
oh oh who's are you using now probably
still a draw though
but yeah i don't know why we're not
thinking
interesting but maybe not actually maybe
not what is he doing
we're not sure people are losing losing
their minds knight takes b5 check king
c4 is the problem yeah he couldn't do it
earlier but he would be able to do this
now played with one second on the clock
yeah okay so this should be winning now
this should be now a technical task
we're going to see
bishop and knight versus king
maybe night check checkmate
maybe
oops it's actually not that easy to win
the f7 pawn without moving the knight
away from uh from the c7 square well you
don't need it you can play yeah oh
that's a thing
okay i don't want you to get the two
minutes that's not enough
illegal move i'm a little bit too
disgusted by all of this stuff yeah like
get me out of there
get me out of there normally you would
see that at the end of the day not uh
this early yeah and uh on the topic of
people laughing after losing games which
has become kind of a hot button topic
recently right
this is sort of genuine enjoyment just i
mean he's obviously he's not happy but
right shark there like giggling giggling
for five seconds straight it it's not a
pose he's just like he he likes playing
chess he's not very
results orientated that felt like the
hot potato the proverbial with the with
the point being passed around the table
uh a lot but let's take a look at that
illegal move this is not what you see
every day amongst 2 800 players no not
very usually and it's coming it's coming
up
[Music]
as soon as we uh
move our pieces backwards shaq thinks
it's time to yeah he'll go up the board
when they're bishop b slash c1 for a
second and then correctly himself which
was a nice touch once again it's uh
right somewhere in between yeah this
bishop could become a dark square bishop
at the moment really like it's going to
be like
yeah it feels like it's on the verge of
becoming a dark square bishop half the
time and now here we go there we go nice
there we go and jan says come on come on
come on what's going on okay so shaq
enough
wow oh
wonderful very very eventful three
rounds and we are going to take a look
at our leaderboard very shortly uh
that was fun that was that was uh
enjoyable in a strange sort of way
exactly it's strange when i
and i have made illegal moves in my life
and usually in my blitz games my
opponent accepts them it's like yeah
yeah yeah
yeah good move goodbye
continue
moving swiftly on but i really hate it
christian don't you when your opponent
points out that you made an illegal move
absolutely obviously and in general
first of all you don't lose the game
automatically right right you can still
continue the game your opponents
on the clock but i guess shaq uh and i
think this rule has changed quite
recently maybe a couple of years ago
back in the days in blitz uh portions
whenever you were making a illegal move
you immediately lose on the spot now
things have changed your opponent gets a
couple of minutes on the cloud but
obviously it's very shameful right
you get red and especially if you're on
camera now let's take a look at some of
the critical moments that we missed
while we were looking at the games this
position the one between aronian versus
uh fabiano after the move rook to c6 we
were looking at it and we were
considering c5 good move d5 which was
played in the game could move as well
but why not just solidify your advantage
with the move a3 right
does feel like the easy way out right
you still have your two trunks you can
play the move c5 next you can play the
move uh d5 next and black doesn't
actually have any counter chances in the
position to create anything against your
king or against any of your weaknesses
because you don't have any weaknesses in
your position as white after the move d5
there were a lot of cool moments in this
game but this one in particular they got
to the end game and it already felt and
i think you guys were mentioning as well
it felt like black pretty much got back
into the game maybe even better at this
point
one thing that is very easy to miss
after king takes uh g7 rook to b1 knight
to c3 take on b4 check
this was the critical sequence that it
does feel like aronian uh missed king
goes to h2 and there is another way to
bring another resource into the attack
and take advantage of the fact that your
king is a little bit stuck boxed in on
h2 with this beautiful move g4 now rook
to h5 from c5 is coming with devastating
consequences there is no way out but to
give up the piece with the move knight
to f3 and this is how uh
ended up a piece up now another a big
moment let me take a look at this game
between furuja and hikaru and let's go
all the way down
and look at this idea of g4 i think this
was a critical idea because
bishop f5 has to be controlled you
cannot allow the bishop to go to f5 or
even the knight to go to f5 it would
control too many squares of this queen
the problem is and the key in this
position is that your queen cannot move
you would love to be able to go queen to
e8 or queen to e7 queen to f7 bring it
closer to the king you cannot move my
rock on e1 is protecting that e file
very nicely and if you do go knight to
f7 then i can just simply improve my
position knight to f3 you still don't
have any active play at some point it
does feel like you will have to give me
uh this pawn on f6 with the move queen
to c7 but if that happens i already have
three pawns on this side this is
tremendous compensation and with such a
weak king and only a few seconds left on
your clock this would be a very very
difficult defense for black so big
missed opportunity for ali reza in uh
this game and let me take a look yes at
this game between shanklin and jeffrey
and at some point i think peter was
saying that jeffrey is just a queen up
how did he get to that situation well
let's take a look
this was a critical moment after rook to
e8 the queen in the middle of the board
actually will get trapped bishop to b5
would have been the only way out but
after the move bishop to e2 which makes
a lot of sense now all of black species
except well actually the queen as well
will uh cooperate to catch to trap this
queen with a move bishop to g4 queen to
g3 knight to h5 you don't have the h4
square because my queen on the 8 is
protecting that this is not possible
your queen is trapped and after queen
takes g4 which you have to sacrifice the
queen in this way this is just a winning
position for black and geoffrey went on
and converted smoothly a very very
important victory for the american
absolutely these are our standings with
alireza still in uh in pole position but
uh mvl there only half a point behind
and then a somewhat steep drop between
uh second and third
uh the shahriar and sam shanklin died
for third
uh
on eleven points uh jan and jeffrey are
on fifty percent on ten and a half and
then uh uh fabian picaro on uh nine and
a half out of currently what is it
twenty one yeah
uh levon is in ninth and linear isn't
clear eighth not really uh having a
particularly productive day
so far
exactly hikaru with two and a half out
of three just drew with the black pieces
against our tournament leader still uh
somebody to uh watch and lots of more
events coming our way of course
immediately following the rapid and
blitz we have the granddaddy of the mall
the final stop of the grand chess tour
the sinkville cup that's starting august
31st goes through september 13th here at
the st louis chess club in st louis
missouri that's followed by the ultimate
moves yeah that's a that's a fun event
which uh
maybe yeah i've become very fond of yeah
it's a little trash talking uh program
coming up and then of course the bobby
fischer or the chess 960 chess nine lx
as we call it here in st louis champion
showdown that's immediately following uh
the sink field and
ultimate moves and then finally our us
and u.s women's chess championships that
will be in october right this summer of
chess absolutely that we've had uh here
uh yeah using using the word summer very
liberally there yeah yeah fall and
since it's fashionable
october which i think is nobody's
definition of summer necessarily but no
we'll see exactly and our parents for
this the fourth round uh peter let's
take a look fabi is white against lanier
uh nippon she is white against sheila
grav which probably is the game to watch
that's going to be our marquee match up
here
uh jeffrey shong is white against
jacqueline minjarov nakamura shanklin is
an interesting one sam won the rapid one
right between those two players and
levon is playing against the tournament
leader alireza
uh levan is struggling
yeah the one is in trouble surprisingly
to me
has he lost all his games after this
point um
i think he drew one but
he won actually in the first
round against jeffrey
and then he lost a couple
yeah yes he lost against karu and
yeah but uh
i'm keeping an eye on the live ratings
and hikaru is now enjoying a very clear
lead he is on currently on 20 28
68.4 live rating in clear first he was
tied for first before the tournament
started at 21.51 dropping below fabi and
fabi is on 2846. that's an important
consolation price for hikaru after
losing 47 grading points in the rapids
yeah the rapid really did not go
according to plan four
and sam shanklin uh entered uh the blitz
with with the lowest blitz rating of any
of the competitors how's sam doing and
the light is he is he increased his
still
he might be he might be by the time
we're done with the tournament all right
very very good anything in particular
going to stand out for you this is the
blitz's blitz uh some uh
honestly it's it's such a weird thing to
point out but it really
kind of attracted my attention we've had
what 15 games of blitz and we've had i
think four or five of those
end games with an extra piece and pawns
on one side yeah and it's it's such a
niche end game and they all sort of you
know as london buses tend to do yeah
yeah they all come all at once yeah it's
it's it's not something that
is extremely important but it did
definitely draw my eye because i think
you know you can go years without
thinking
like a
rook and knight and three pawns versus a
rook and four on the same side
absolutely yeah very interesting that
that that occurred like that
at first i thought i was on the wrong
board
when i was flipping
because there was two games with rook at
night
and how about for you
christian anything
uh stand out uh one player getting in a
did time travel over another well
definitely hikaru is standing out he's
playing marvelous chess and has the
option of uh and the opportunity to
continue doing so against what i see as
a struggling sam shanklin he played a
brilliant
rapid portion as a wild card came into
this event as a rapid uh wild card and
he could have easily won the rapid
section right now unfortunately sam is
struggling a little bit hikaru huge
opportunity also the young ali brezza is
definitely feeling the nerves but he's
handling them quite well up to this
point still six rounds to go in today's
rounds for me
along with icaro i always thought that
nepo
was
ready to shift gears and get into a
higher gear but he got
knocked down in that first game with
farouja that was that uh
reverse sicilian if you will
and uh
well
i mean for for me if nepo gets into a
high gear gear that would be something
to watch now tell me a little bit more
about the shirt this is the paint splash
yeah i'm not i don't i mean this is a
very strange shirt by the standards of
this field i came to fight exactly
not really much to remark upon even man
right i was uh you know when i saw it
from the back i thought maybe maybe jan
decided to regale us with his diet
hunter shirt but no no no no tight
hunter today
i'm not even sure he brought it which is
honestly a huge letdown seriously just
depressing
now one thing that's been on my mind for
some time and i've been wanting to ask
you about it
magnus
declining to play the world championship
how was that taken by yourself
personally and in russia
i'm not
i don't really know you know
i'm not going to pretend i can speak for
the entire country but right uh you know
this debate continued for a number of
debates may be strong but uh
but magnus was pretty much on the record
saying that he was very seriously
considering not playing the next one and
not not just this but even some of the
previous ones he was he was saying that
perhaps he will not play and i think a
lot of people for uh whatever reasons
you can you can guess that the reasons i
think for for a lot of people the idea
of not playing the world championship
match
both for you know purely pragmatical and
also for you know the the glory reasons
right was so unthinkable that they
assumed he is just
kind of you know preening and
and and joking around but i always
my feeling is that uh
magnus generally gives the the most
honest
interviews great and straightforward
press conferences
of i think almost anyone in the chess
world right now so if he's if he's
saying he might not play i always take
him at his word yeah i always took it to
me and he might not play right and uh i
wasn't shocked it's obviously not great
news for the chess world let's not let's
not be a bit about the bush there but
but obviously in this case uh nepo is in
the world championship match
and uh yeah they're repeating they're
repeating their game from the rapid in
which uh jan had a very very good
position we were kind of
we waltzed past the moment i discussed
it with him afterwards there was a
particular moment in that game where he
was basically winning
straight out of the opening oh and nbl
event we saw captures and then e6 bishop
b5 was played i believe right uh queen
d6 uh perhaps
again
from the rapid game it was taken
i think i think e6
and yeah they've kind of progressed i
think this is actually still theory yeah
f3
i believe i've seen this position before
but maybe not yeah i think they've
deviated from what they were uh playing
in the rapid and surprisingly jan
actually had this on the black side
against dude in 2021 i see on your
screen i'm not trying to show off my
knowledge i don't really know i was
going to say very impressive no no no no
you could just recall it so i can i can
read your screen very good so yeah this
is a reasonably central position of the
entire line we're still following some
reasonably high rated games and answer
gear have had this
uh on the white side last year
um
a blitz game one thing probably doesn't
give us enough time to go into too much
detail about the strategic strategic
intricacies of this but
we've seen in the rapid game that if you
don't play extremely precisely you will
be in trouble the question is how much
trouble right
and uh obviously with this being the
repetition of a game they played two
days ago mvl
was always unlike was always unlikely to
come completely unprepared right so we
we can assume that this is an
improvement on over what he did in the
rapid
on your chassis of course i mean the
groom is like a universal
it's such a very very very big universe
uh
i wanted to ask you in your chest of
course if you looked at this line and
you just i i chose i emphasis
it's a
i made a very conscious choice to give
something completely different again
different against bishop c4 specifically
because of this setup i think i even
mentioned one of the yeah in one of the
sort of
semi-introductory videos to the course i
did mention that i would have very
happily given b6 against the bishop c4
systems in the grand field if not for
the existence of these types of setups
which have become
uh you know ubiquitous everybody is
playing this with white right now and if
you play b6 on blue 10 you're extremely
likely to get a position such as this
one
and i think it's just not very enjoyable
so i chose to recommend something else
my recommendation comes with its own set
of problems i'm not right i'm not
entirely happy with everything there
universal panacea
solved everything but i didn't really
like the nature of these positions i
disliked enough to not even give them at
all
well that's that's and i think you're
recommending g4 and knight yeah i i gave
the old main line bishop g4 3985 which
requires something that's so
something that i really just like as a
groomfield player i always tried
memorization to play to play lines which
don't require you to memorize 30 moves
of forced variations which unfortunately
bishop g4 knight a5 really clearly
clearly it clearly does require you to
remember a lot of stuff
but
this i disliked more okay what's
happening here peter now let's talk
about it it's become very sharp queen
rook c8 you have to play rook c8 and
then i wanted to capture i think knight
takes e5 is playable otherwise this
would be kind of borderline losing for
black but i think we can go ruxin g595
okay yeah i think this is kind of just
very very important it feels precarious
but i don't
see have any g5 maybe yeah sorry
christian please do you have time to go
d5 but you know you're not much better
though you you might have to but you're
not much better i will note that jeffrey
shong is a full piece up by move 10
against yeah somehow i have no idea how
a few piece droppings uh going on uh
takes on e5 and this is the moment of
truth you said knight takes i think i
think you can yeah well he goes e8 which
is i guess he means he means to say that
the pawn on e5 cannot really escape and
he doesn't really need to be playing end
games just yet because knight takes 5
would have offered an end game doesn't
uh bishop we still have an id5 there
right i'm trying to take on g7 and h5
soften up the king side a wee little bit
yeah bishop f6 knight e5 g5 have been a
fault no yes
i guess the queen f4 it feels like the
way they go i don't
think f4 it does nothing it doesn't
support the pawn because we have this
x-ray along the c file meaning that
knight takes e5 will be available pretty
much against any move you would you know
care to mention yes um i think this is
not that horrible for black the bishop
on b7 is a bit stupid uh being very very
well restrained by the pawns on f3 and
d4
but the bishop on b5 is no oil painting
either so
um i think this is you know kind of
acceptable for black i'm i wouldn't be
extremely happy here with black but i
feel like it's probably manageable
knight takes e5 queen f4 there's even
yeah queen a4
you could yeah
you could definitely play queen a4 ask
ask where this rook is going i'm
guessing it actually goes kind of
modestly
i limp towards my king yeah you know
as a grunfeld player yourself uh
christian i'm sure it it warms your
heart to see your favorite defense on
the board
how do you evaluate this is the reason
why i don't play the b6 line as well
against this bishop to c4 i try to
follow peter everywhere he goes
he's a good guy yes he's a good guy to
follow him
i want to see my heart
by this point mvl is my guide in many
many lines of the greenville but just
not here i actually he was one of the
people who sort of introduced the idea
of playing b6 to me
i played i played b6 a decent amount
myself i'm not entirely unfamiliar with
it but
uh
for a time if you played b6 you had to
be prepared for some extremely sharp
extremely concrete variations
which if you knew what you were doing
were basically draws
and that was fine but now what you get
is this yeah and this i really really
kind of dislike as a greenfield player
queen d2
a3 bishop a2 is something i'm also
looking at because a3 bishop a2 oh a4 i
don't know which one i kind of like a3
for some reason but a4 is also a move i
would i would definitely consider
something yes
yeah a4 played i was about to say you
could actually play bishop c2 with the
same idea which may have been the best
of the
three let's
let's try to create some kind of chances
sorry let's go b5 before bishop a2
are you threatening anything i'm not
sure yeah i don't know why i'm allowing
b takes before to be honest maybe i
shouldn't be alive
it kind of has that feeling that uh
you're going to have to be very careful
uh i get it probably uh for example if i
try to go rook to c2 right now i think
rook d8 might just look at me five yeah
is the tactic this is why i was trying
to play bishop
exactly uh which was actually kind of a
funny move right it's a keyboard i think
it may have been stronger than any any
of the other two yeah just play bishop
c2 here with the atm bishop b3 right and
ruxin 25 has resigned so yes
so a4 bishop pardon me bishop secretary
66.
so he's going to do
right click why can't you take on a4
jesus second i'm going to do my promote
variation ah
yeah yeah bishop bishop a2 played bishop
a4 i guess he wants to define
him
yeah once we
once and if we remove the the knight
from the e5 square our attack will start
developing very very quickly exactly i
love these ideas of room t5 and 95
and this is once again this is why this
this
idea of pushing the h pawn up to h6 is
always going to be unbelievably
unpleasant to to black in all of these
structures the alpha zero yeah bishop e8
rook c5 is a kind of a clever way but
now that nice c3
that was nicely done
c3 looks very very promising uh may i
bring my colleague to the d5 square
knight c3
i very much like this move yeah i think
i think he played it you know i think
you you can't allow this knight to land
on d5 so it becomes very very like you
might have to play bishop c6
and hope that you somehow prevent it
from landing their number six queen e5
queenie fighters i don't know because
you still have the control over the
square
yeah queen e5 queen e5 mate yeah
we have rookie five for q5 bishop f7 but
i don't think it's enough it's playable
but i don't think it actually wins the
game
it's definitely playable it looks looks
it's almost promising enough right it
looks very interesting if we can like
rookie five rookie five we take on f7
the king has to go to h8 yes and then we
can play for instance bishop d5 there is
one knight g5 i don't know which one you
like better i think bishop d5 pro there
is this uh queen check that just kind of
annoyed me because i can't rather yeah
for the moment go to the age but i still
have king f1 after queen yeah
i think i think we're getting carried
away i think we absolutely don't have to
do any of that he took it he took only
five he did it we're going straight into
that line yeah okay so bishop f7 will be
will will be play king king h8 will also
be played because otherwise we should
take g6 discover check or anything else
and now the big question here you go on
bishop d5 do you go knight g5
i think white runs zero risks regardless
of which he chooses but the question is
whether you can actually uh win
a claim of an advantage so bishop d5
probably you have to go bishop because
he goes 95. you can't tolerate this
knife it will get taken off the board
i'm pretty sure i mean queen d6 exists
but i think but what about queen c5 now
i can eat i can go to g3 honestly i
don't see you probably have to yes but
also like i think i don't mind it it's
extremely dangerous for black to leave
leave the control over the like
background
square yeah yeah the queen needs to stay
on e7
so we're reckoning bishop takes d5
bishop takes d5 and then maybe g5 i mean
more or less box the way the way for
black to try and improve here would be
to play g5 and to try to get after the
pawn on h6
but what about queen d6 right now he's
gone queen whoa whoa we all
missed that square completely oh dear
and that would be a reason yeah and
wait wait h2 no allowing queen check on
c1 this cannot be better than a purpose
yeah i think he's not better
i mean he's quite clearly now very happy
with the perpetual but i think he
probably doesn't have the perpetual
quincy one queen g2 i guess he goes to
f1 and he's very lucky he played yeah
that yeah
yeah yeah
extremely lucky he played a4 all those
moves back yeah but
yeah and i think andrea will give a
check from d4 and then reconsider yeah
yeah this is very clever he'll give a
check from defaulting
the question
why he's one of the best blitz players
in the world king g3
bishop takes a four and you know that i
thought it was time to play king g3
75
i'm skewered
yes or as dorsey would say shish kebab
yeah bishop a4 played bishop b5 check
king e1 uh queen g1 i'm not sure i i
suspect you might still have to take
that perpetual yeah if you take on g2
king c3 you probably resign oh that's
weird there's still queen
he
back to g5 which would have been
hilarious because then after queen h2 is
kind of a reset yeah please play queen
h2 again dear sir yeah but he did not
and he's on 10 seconds
by the way uh christian did i could you
just confirm that we've got a win by
fabi yes fabiano has won his game
against linear dominguez so king e1 is a
threefold or maybe not a threefold yet
but it might be
yep i think he's they're asking for an
arbiter yeah so nba i think uh nbl
hadn't realized that queen g5 uh
you could have done it again yeah um
interesting game let's just quickly jump
to uh the game still ongoing yeah this
is uh uh
a couple of pawns up and the the counter
play really isn't very much
the big question here yeah the big
question is the clock yeah they're both
on 10 seconds so yeah this is queen b7
see one of the things i mean i would be
tempted to go knight takes a 4 against
somebody in 10 seconds it doesn't work
though yeah knight f6 oh god
i wanted to
play h2 but it's not a legal move
because uh because yeah you yeah now
queen of three queen of finish one check
knight h5 back queen of three
yeah it's it's just so annoying to play
on 10 seconds with white like you know
you're winning but of course but like
how exactly exactly uh how exactly clean
to check now you're not winning maybe
oh g4 g5 g5 i know now g4 g5 he will
lose the queen on h2 and resign yeah
okay so hicaro ends up clutching it uh
in
at the very very end the game between
the one running and there's a few ended
yeah this is the final position actually
what you're watching on the board right
there with them discussing is the final
position no other pieces naked kings
no other pieces left so this concludes
the round with hikaru winning
and uh jeffrey winning and uh fabi
winning so actually three wins for white
and a couple of draws there a very
eventful one in the nippom nishi
mvl game we you know for for a change we
picked really really well i think we
picked up very interesting yeah normally
we
we we're we're not so good uh
that final that was going on between
nakamura and sam shanklin christian that
was a little shaky i'll have to take a
look at that one because i was uh
looking at the game between jeffrey and
mom and mirov and trying to see what
happened
and it was actually jeffrey who was
winning after like five moves or
something along those lines yeah yeah
that's what this is ridiculous before
castle
knight to e2 c6 and this is already a
huge mistake that actually gives the
game away you have to play knight to c6
and then you continue the game uh
without the bishop pair still white
preserves the advantage nevertheless
after c6 the problem is you have so many
weaknesses in the position after bishop
to g5 which was played you would expect
black to play something along the lines
of knight to d7 the problem is after
castle you're just simply losing the
pawn on a d6 you're in big big trouble
not only that but i also have ideas of
potentially knight to f4 uh knight to h5
in the future but
without the pawn on d6 without the
bishop air you cannot expect too much
nevertheless check this out so after
bishop g5 d5 was played inexplicable
allowing the move e5 queen to b4 is
going to be met by bishop to d2 that's a
check that's a counter and then you
still are losing a piece queen takes c4
queen take c4 will exchange and then you
lose the knight on f6
just a blindness from mamedyaro very
early blindness because after e5 you
lose a piece you play the move c5 queen
to f4 rook to e8 and this is a piece up
you can resign basically after um
13 moves of play wow not that bad now
jeffrey went on and won quite a smooth
game after that
nepo versus uh mvl and i think you guys
were mentioning it this was the big
moment right right d5 queen to g5 which
was missed queen to c1 but as you guys
were
mentioning bishop takes a four good move
big queen to f4 and i would expect that
this is what he missed after queen takes
g2 king to c3 he missed the square g5
pretty sure
now this basically this uh forces the
queen trade you can go queen to h2 but
then you have to tend with a lot more
checks after queen to c1 you're in
trouble and also your queen is not
coming back into play anytime soon black
is definitely winning also you cannot go
into the end game because a big missed
opportunity i have to say uh by mvl who
was in fact on the back foot and then
after this move queen to h2 was allowed
this opportunity to potentially win the
game and ali rezak with a win by the way
mvl would have caught up ali reza now
she's half a point behind but there's a
big gap between the first two and the
pack and look at this jeffrey clear
third there yes yeah suffering clear
third and then arrow climbing his way up
yeah yeah
carol doing his best he's on three and a
half out of four so far today obviously
uh sort of winning the blitz tournament
so far right he started by giving such a
handicap to the field that he still only
died for seventh one point behind the
podium though
yeah so that's not that that's not bad
at all now
on our break when we were talking i was
asking both you and christian and said
okay ikaro started in 10th position how
is he going to finish the day
and christian said in the top half
meaning
you went in the top three yeah kind of
expecting him to do it
through the field
i think for for a player like like your
car if he wins the first couple uh gets
that yeah he gets gets that additional
win in his sales i think he's extremely
dangerous and uh i could very easily see
him and absolutely having an absolute
absolutely fantastic day if he scores
something like i know six and a half out
of nine
which from a point where he is now it's
just plus one plus one in the rest of
the day right he probably will be around
the top three so yeah i think i think i
kind of stand by my prediction that was
two rounds ago very good well we're
going to take another short break and
we'll see on the other side
[Music]
hey st louis the ascension charity
classic presented by emerson is back
this september don't miss the excitement
when the pga tour champions best compete
again all for charity september 9th
through the 11th at norwood hills
country club pro-am spots hospitality
packages vip tickets and more available
now at ascensioncharityclassic.com
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello and welcome back to st louis rapid
and blitz with round five coming up so
the midway of the day will be somewhere
during this round
and these are you these are your
standings after four rounds of blitz as
you can see there the blitz tournament
that is currently in progress today is
being convincingly won by hikaru
nakamura with three fighter four yeah
but the the double points in rapid are
so important that even with that very
very dominant result he's still only
tied for seven and the two frenchmen are
still very very healthily up top there
with alireza on 13 and a half
an mbl there on 13th but with nine blitz
games uh can hikara close that
three-point gap talking of which what
about our parents for this round five
people in round five we have dominguez
chief erosion caruana aronian
sean maksim plays white against
shankland and shakhtaryamundaraf is
playing against hikaru and kamuro i'd
like fallujah and currywanda to be our
marquee matchup
how do you guys feel about that i think
that's a good one that's a good idea by
the way why does perugia have six points
in that i think that that's just a
that was a mess up
we're gonna we're gonna chalk that one
up to uh uh our producer time i know
fabi won three and lost two i think so
he's definitely on three out of five on
this one but i wasn't sure what we
usually was doing there with six
a lot of smiles with the players uh very
friendly atmosphere it strikes me peter
i think it's just a like this field is
generally very very comfortable with
each other and also i think people just
generally enjoy playing blitz truly i
think it just bleeds into their mood
very much because they're yes there's a
lot of money and pride at stake and so
on
but
it's at stake while they're doing
something they all genuinely enjoy
exactly and this this really
i think you can see in their faces
oftentimes uh when i was playing uh
professionally um
with the presence of the world champion
somehow the move became a bit more
serious imagine uh magnus in this field
i don't think
no i think i think
would be grinning
yeah more than anybody else i think he
loves blitz and i think yeah it would
just improve the mood if if if anything
might be wonderful to answer your
question yes sir last time i was uh well
i think it was warsaw magnus was there
immediately after his decision and i
think he was in a pretty decent mood as
well and everybody else uh was
let's say not feeling his tense presence
in any way shape or form ah very good
nice to hear that
and look at that fabby's representing
the rapid and blitz i mean he's got uh
the logo on his t-shirt everybody
representing go go to cue boutique and
be like
unfortunately flowers are not available
broke the 2850 barrier and uh oh hicaro
is up to 2873 on the live list obviously
there is still
what is it uh
14 games of blitz left so obviously too
early to count
having said that does that mean that
fabi moves up to number two in the world
number two in the world yes wow and
fabio was very close to actually winning
the world uh police championship wasn't
he
i think he finished he he drew his last
game quite quickly against uh nepo he
made this really
which was a very weird and
uncharacteristic for him decision not to
play that last round which i think
immediately disqualified him from the
fight for first because he had poor tie
breaks but he was doing really well in
that tournament he also
uh by a kind of a freak of nature did
not win the uh
extremely strong blitz tournament after
the grand swiss in 2021
where uh his direct pursuer well or not
pursuer but the the person he was
fighting for the first place with
uh
his opponent in the last round blundered
mate in one which doesn't happen every
day
by the way a repeat of the open sicilian
uh more of that yeah
yes e4 per me
knight b6 by the way is not the only
move in that position
they keep on playing it as a matter of
course but it's not really the only move
young played a five here let's see what
uh what fabi comes with the f5 before
before we'll be back to that game i
think fabi probably will
uh refrain from playing uh five or fours
early you can play a6 now
because the the i think the knight from
b1 very
sort of generally it gets developed to
g2
uh my board seems to be stuck things are
things are a little bit stuck but maybe
they will they will unstick in a moment
why that's that uh is the case i will
make the moves myself yeah and this is
what i expected yeah five starts with
a6 and alireza goes knight bg2 and now
you can play a four and the bishop
cannot go back all the way to c1 and
goes to c5 instead
an improvement if you will which i think
is an improvement because we can trade
it off and we also as you can very
clearly see from how fabulous treating
it we are not committed not at all to
the plan of playing g5 h5 and giving
mate we are
playing a much more i think it will
unstick in a moment here i think the
moves are now starting to come in so
okay
uh in the meantime we have plenty of
other action but we should be sticking
with this one it's an interesting
reversal
i try to refresh my board yeah it'll
it'll come yet so they're coming slowly
but they will come yeah and nothing out
of the ordinary is happening in the
other not very much it's a kind of a
typical uh typical position as i said
this is very clearly a reverse night or
if you really shouldn't be describing
any other way it looks like an english
but really it's a
it's a sicilian i still like white's
position uh i like what fabi is doing
much more than what jan was doing
exactly yeah i was basically just dead
loss
15 there yeah but
even so even so i like the inclusion of
king aj just getting
it doesn't recapture with check
i'm agreeing with you yeah i i am
playing king h8 here uh
the moment i have d4 is on the board
guys
looks really good yeah d4 and he's gone
bishop b3 queen b3
um i guess he will take on d4
and then after bishop i mean
even knight takes the voice playable
honestly i i don't like this one i think
before bishop takes
c5 you have what move knight c6 rook of
two six bishop takes off yeah i i still
feel like white is better there you also
have knight six that might be a problem
c6 yeah he did take with the bishop
bishop and knight also creates a threat
of light
yeah
oops ori
fd1 actually right this looks crushing
honestly
uh sorry this looks this looks extremely
strong
i'm just going to refresh my board i
apologize for that uh i resonate once
really enjoy five
d1
looks borderline winning for white once
again we're we're at move 19
english wins or reverses yeah yeah
whatever you want to call it just gives
yeah 25 yeah for fabi doesn't need to
resign just yet but it's going to be a
horrible endgame after let's say 25 and
94 quite simply or queen b1 which is
what alireza chose yeah queen d1 also
hinting at c7 getting getting mated
bishop to d3 yeah no this is just
horrible for fabi just absolutely
horrible
wow
and the engines actually agree with you
guys
it's really bad
unsurprisingly i just i mean well this
isn't expected to
this position if you told me was plus
three i kind of go yeah i understand but
the other one
when when when you were a bit shocked
with the other one yeah yeah you can go
bishop d3 here and perhaps it kind of
invites queen h a queen queen g8 but
like there's nothing wrong with rook
takes d4 absolutely absolutely nothing
wrong with just taking the pawn winning
a tempo but then queen e6
you can sort of see that if black
doesn't lose on the spot you can see the
outlines of how you can try to equalize
there with like you you use the g-file
to trade as many prices as possible
eventually you put the knight on d5 and
you uh
hope to
to still be alive at the end of all that
but i
gotcha so rook takes d4 queen e6 i
don't see really
i couldn't go queen e4 and rook d1 but i
don't see a knockout yeah i mean white
clearly is
for choice very very much in control but
yeah
the position looks good enough for you
to actually look for a winning advantage
right by the way guys jeffrey against
mvl with the black pieces he's gaining
quite a significant advantage we yeah we
don't really need to perhaps
not move to the beach just to kind of
give you an update it's uh it's it's on
the edge is what you're telling us
in the in the meantime yep
so clearly yeah i love your bishop to d3
immediately yeah and and tickle the h7
pawn idea yeah he's still gonna do it
here g6 i mean you can't play h6 if you
play h6 you get mated and now yeah g6 is
forced
but now rook d8 is about to finally
happen you can maybe play for bishop c2
bishop b3 but that seems slow is bishop
c4 ridiculous knight c4 rook c4
i was going to try to you know what i
mean yeah i mean yeah i know yeah i know
bond grabber it's bad everything is bad
i think he went h4 judging by that hand
movement he went h4 he did with the
suggestion that you know i will just
play h5 next move and uh break
everything open but there there is king
g7 there in the end honestly it feels
like this is a huge improvement for 5b
right he will at least be alive by move
25 which honestly it fell yeah and then
go there for a moment at the 19 move
mark it really felt like it might not be
the case
okay g8 if you if you take on the 8 and
you play h5 i will play king g7 and that
that preserves my king side structure
sort of intact yeah while we also as
black succeeded in
getting some material off the board i
think and crucial for uh this game is
also that ferruja only has two minutes
left while fabi three minutes and 20
seconds
that's a big time difference right there
takes takes rookie one play
rook d8 and rookie one i could have
played rook d8
and invited a trade i assume
uh the queen would have gone to g4 in
that case and knight f3 but
okay we have this situation yeah i think
i think we throw in king g7 somewhere so
that h5 comes as a kind of a less of a
blow because h5 is eventually coming i
don't think we can really play h4 for a
reason um nepal with a big chance right
now to prevent potentially get a winning
advantage if he finds the right move
whoa whoa whoa what about this move
knight a4 though is that stepping in the
wrong direction i'm not sure i i think
he wants to go like b5 followed by c5
fight he wants active counter player
quincy he will play b5
and then he will play c5 next move which
if it all comes off for him i i very
much endorse because you do want to
start disrupting the y let's go h5 h5
king g7 i think we're always playing g7
and then we want to play c5 and ask
alireza do you want to allow c4 or do
you want to take bc and
give me those tempe even here
i mean i don't like giving up the ball
on f4 but i'm still probably playing c5
on it c5 rookie rook f4 c4 bishop b4 i
don't know knight b6 and playing this
position the rook on the 4 is kind of
misplaced i want to play 95. ask you to
trade the bishop uh we do have a result
hikaru versus shakriyah yeah that wasn't
a very exciting game we don't need to go
there
but for hikaru his streak
is kind of being stalled yeah but i
think i think
the good thing about hikara and his
approach to blitz is that he he still
preserves a lot of objectivity he still
preserves a lot of kind of calmness he
doesn't need to even when he's in three
and a half out of four
you know if shaq plays some kind of a
theoretical line against him which ends
in the draw he just he just plays the
thing
ends it in the draw and uh says okay
this was a black game i no longer have
to play it very good uh yeah c5 look for
but in the meantime on the board by the
way uh one move that i wanted to say i
didn't look at bishop c4
i blundered that and uh alireza didn't
yeah
the rest is on point yeah okay and he
did and that's pawn number two yeah
peter that yeah this very much very much
discourages me from my
one early enthusiasms about the slide
one you can live with it's the second
one i think i think this is done now
because you can create a passer on c3 it
gets blockaded by the queen on c2 and
the biggest issue is that the bish point
seven is just completely disconnected
from all of that so i can go let's say
rookie four rookie three and slowly
slowly and start pushing yeah
and g4 as
alireza has
chosen while the pawn on c3 is alive of
course the game still continues but yeah
it's it this has to be winning for white
technically
this has to be winning for white in the
meantime uh it looks like uh yanni
palmish is completely winning with the
black pieces against linear dominguez
lanier's been fading yeah linear has not
had a good day and he's all he's also i
think not had a good day last day of of
wrapping up
he's very much in trouble okay
what if i go queen of five right now is
this that easy i mean i think you have
to go 91 and then i pick up the e5 pawn
yeah uh
this is yeah i thought rookie four was
much more uh much more logical you
cannot go rookie four right now but no
you take on e4 and c2 yeah previous move
not not yeah
exactly i was thinking that the rook was
going to go to e4 go to e3 tie you to
the pawn and then one day i would crack
it with h5 and yeah i think the fight
was probably missed and now you're in
particular this being a blitz game
this is no longer trivial
at all no at all no no i mean this this
clearly was if i take on f5 rook c1 and
then you go away
i go e5 either probably immediately yeah
probably immediately don't put the pawn
on c2 so you don't have to worry about
knight no exactly but then i'll go
knight d4 so queen f5 gf5 rook d1
a5 rook c1 a b a b
bishop b4 knight d4 yeah give me the f5
well he's gone he's gonna go on c1 which
is c2 well and we we should be taking
this invitation we should be pushing
this pawn on c2 and just you know be
grateful keeping it there as a
source of uh unnervement yeah i don't
know if that's a word
yeah
by the way uh
yeah
i think we can play bishop takes no no
yeah i thought so too bishop h4
and then the knight returns to f3 which
is what i blundered yeah we can start
with a5 right a5 or we can start with
queen of four actually yeah queen of
four i think is a clever move here no
more knight t1 because
exactly i think everything is completely
hamstrung and we want to play a6a5 i
think you can lose this position with
white truly because you really have no
moves 10 seconds left for our leverage
you can play e6 with the idea
to check but five people just quietly
play king g8 king f1 barely made it on
time a5 a5 keep going four seconds
ah yeah he has rook g8 in the end there
but yeah we have quincy for check if we
need to even immediately this looks like
it might just objectively be winning now
yeah quincy for check followed by eight
eggs before
the policy to a rook g8 is almost
winning on the spot but yeah i think you
go a b a b bishop takes before and then
you go from there you don't need to be
particularly smart clever yeah yeah just
just be be straightforward but the
problem with rook d8 i think was 91 91
exactly this is why yeah i don't know
why we're doing this maybe he calculated
something that's just what you're doing
for check rookie three i don't know why
we've allowed this we might still be
doing very well but i wouldn't have i i
don't see them
he wins the piece with queen c2 and
rugby two so he will not lose the game
but he will probably not win the game
either because that looks like a
defensible endgame
uh yeah we clearly could have could have
cashed in for much much more than this
three seconds
yeah yeah you should you shouldn't play
six but here's a very very low time yeah
yeah i was about to say now king seven
of six that that that move easy
one should never have reached e6 yeah
you should keep it on the dark square
yeah once again this end game yeah game
just keeps on popping up yeah king of
six yeah i would have taken on h4 i
don't think i don't think we needed
rook takes f2 check yeah as well yeah
that as well could have been quite
strong but yeah we
no i think i think this is going wrong
for yeah ali raza has just rook c6 by
this point is kind of winning even i
think because
you you never actually trade those uh
those pawns
i think we can quite safely uh trade
rooks now with rook d6 yes yes yes the h
pawn is of the wrong color but it's
irrelevant because white never actually
trades enough
uh to get to that
yeah he wants rookie six check and then
bishop d6 yeah yeah this actually maybe
shouldn't have been allowed
you're probably still winning but now
you no longer can trade rooks so it
becomes a little bit harder a bit of a
tricky end game yet again
yeah levon olivan won his game against
uh sam shanklin so how do you make any
progress right now
yeah you're in yeah all right i need to
put the bishop on the d force the bishop
needs to get the d4 and then we play
king e4 basically we play for mate for
for the time being i don't know what
this is but
i think he has to say towards the center
yeah
you think i don't know i was okay with
king jitto now bishop g5 f4
well rook check is maybe a little
awkward
i think the king needed to stay on the
kings i don't know what we did there
yeah we
may have kind of blundered our h6 pawn
it has to go but not yet king of six
kings oh yeah yeah we have yeah it's
it's not hanging because we have bishop
d5 check right so we're all right no oh
that works
bishop g5 king king
this this will be a long round now
oh no rook and bishop versus a long
round yeah this this was i mean in a way
i'm i mean loretta was completely
winning so in a way you can't really
begrudge him not not losing this game
but
it was quite the turnaround to be sure
and like i don't know i don't know why
fabi is
continuing this
is time a factor christian
absolutely yes it's eight seconds versus
eight seconds blitz game of course time
is a factor yeah i don't know a huge
factor i i don't know i feel
like well i'm not sure this is a
positive free roll for five years what
i'm saying like he clearly thinks it's a
free roll but i'm not sure if it's a
free roll to win or to lose to beyonce
it's like i think
i think i think of the two of them
well he you know
it's not the the the guy they play with
the the the less likely to blunder you
know right king of six yeah we don't
lose this of course i mean
things really need to go really yeah
just take on g7 please
very nice okay very good very good
neither of them will be happy with this
but
very deserving lisa
any games remaining is that
all
christian i think that was uh that was
the last one
another hot potato being passed that was
quite something yeah
alireza came i think incredibly close i
don't even want to check with the
machine but i'm pretty sure fabi was
winning with the king on it so yes uh
and that was from a position with two
healthy extra pawns which you don't see
very often very often but allowing that
queen f5 move really took the wind out
of the sails uh christian over to you
did you
tell us about some of the other games as
we got mesmerized by our marquis mac
match-up absolutely we had a lot of
decisive uh games one of them was the
one between the struggling dominguez
he's just simply not finding his form in
this tournament particularly in the
blitz section against nepal miyashi
unfortunately for him he got a very good
position very good sicilian position out
of the opening with the white pieces but
unfortunately for him he was unable to
make anything out of uh that bishop to
g7 challenging this very important piece
the bishop on d4 on the long diagonal
this was quite a big mistake queen to a4
would have been the right solution for a
black and just put more and more
pressure with every single move he
decided to go queen to c7 sure it makes
a lot of sense as well setting up this
nice pin against the knight on f4 as
well as ideas of knight takes e4 which
was the key in the position and it was
actually the key that was missed by
dominguez he played the move king to b1
and immediately this was the moment that
i uh alarmed you about during the game
the one where nepo if he would have
found 94 which he did would have won
this game and this is exactly what
happened after bishop takes c4 bishop
takes d4 you can take on d4 with the
rook the problem is you're going to have
to face e5 also bishop takes c4 followed
by queen to c2 so bishop takes c4 you
don't have any protection on the first
rank anymore you can take back on e4 but
this would just lead to a checkmate
queen to c1 take take and that's a
checkmate on the board i do believe that
this is what he missed in the position
and he played the move bishop takes g6 a
desperado solution for uh white but
unfortunately this is simply not enough
i'm not going to take on g6
first i'm going to set up this pin on
with the bishop on e5 not only that but
preserving the dark square bishop in the
position for black also gives me an
amazing shield around the king you're
never going to be able to create any
problems around my king with the bishop
on
e5 bishop takes f7 you can give a check
but i hide all the time on the dark
squares and this was just a simple
conversion for black for yana pomnyashi
who scores a very important victory for
him he started off quite slowly in this
event so far in this portion of the
blitz portion so far and another one was
this game between sam shanklin once
again a player that did amazingly well
in the rapid portion unfortunately for
him struggling in the blitz section
let's take a look at this one
it did seem like black was getting some
sort of an advantage but he let it slip
that is aronian by entering this end
game after queen to g3 queen takes f4
queen takes a rook takes f4 look to d7
it felt like white is very close to
achieving full equality but he was not
there yet rook takes f7 king to g6 rook
to c7 rook to e4 rook to c5 rook to e5
rook to c4 h5 g3 and this was the
critical mistake rook to c3 what you
have to do is maintain an active
approach in the position with the move
rook to a4 not allow your rook to become
passive after this move rook to c4 rook
to c3 excuse me rook to g4 and i'm going
to be able to set up the bind i'm going
to get the rook to a4 and your rook is
going to be stuck to the defense of that
pawn on a3 which will allow me to just
simply push my pawns on this side and
create a decisive advantage and this is
exactly what happened this was the
position rook to c3 h4
now i'm putting the rook to d4 and then
my king is going to come slowly but
surely
unless you just simply give me the other
pawn as well which he did this is a
technical win for a black and aronian
scores i do believe it might be his
first victory in the blitz section very
very important result for him
thank you christian and there we see our
current standings peter yeah the
standings at the top remain the same
with that reza leading the field by half
a point above maximum shallow grave but
now yanipanishi and jeffrey are i mean
that probably is still how it was right
with half a point a point and a half
behind uh mvl with shock now and clear
fifth on uh eleven and a half
uh fabian kikaru and sam shanklin now
all tied
uh for sixth through eighth and then uh
levon and linear having i mean the year
is really having a a nightmare that's
true yeah levon is not really doing
all that well either
but
hikaru that three-point gap and as
magnus is going to be joining the tour
for the sink filled cup how is that
going to impact the grand chester
standings peter uh yeah the standings as
they are right now as you can see on
your screen wesley is leading but with
mvl doing so well
you would assume that nbl probably
overtakes him whereas
actually might not we thought they both
could overtake him but exactly levon
would need to have a very very uh good
rest of the day today and a very good
day tomorrow uh to perhaps get above uh
above wesley right um and then uh fabio
is in the mix if he has a tremendous
chance yeah but fabi could have yeah and
s4 as for you know magnus's
participation in the tour i think what
that does to the tour is that it
basically takes money out of the
ecosystem right
right there's a disinflation if you will
right magnus magnus will play in the
sink field cup and
you would expect him to finish in the
top half of the ball of the standings
there right kind of which means that he
will take some of the points not being
able to participate
so that means that perhaps there will be
uh less
less on offer yes and if we just show
that grand chess tour as a standings
once more i just want to point out
why i think that this game that bobby
just
lets slip you see
bobby needs that 13 points to jump past
wesley a big score and if we'll go now
to the game of farouza once i once the
pawn got to c2 wasn't fabby winning did
he like he was literally but i think i i
i briefly looked at this if we if we go
a bit further after yeah
is a mistake uh instead of a five years
old but specifically in this position
after aba b5 he actually took some time
and played rogue d8 and i now realize
what he didn't see
uh he of course he wanted to play rook
takes bishop takes before sorry instead
of rogue d rigid is still winning but
it's
this is the kind of obvious but now but
now 94
95 94 and your bishop a3 idea which
would have been winning with knight on
f3 now runs into queen takes c2 and we
have the same end game as in the game
it's better for black but you're not
really winning or just not immediately
but after 94 the heartless engine
suggests 94 rook a8
and white is still completely tied up
with the idea of meeting queen c2 with
rocket so clear and this is still
completely winning but i think on like
30 seconds which i think what five years
good luck
yeah
is a tough choice but after he what he
played
did
i mean later he's still winning uh that
is to say fabi when he wins the piece
but uh rook d eight night 91 you have to
go back to c8 the machine says also
simple yeah also not a move that it's
very easy to make in practical terms
just returning and kind of admitting a
mistake but again fabi wins this game
knocks down ali raza gives himself a
chance to grab those crucial
grandchildren absolutely
it's only a big mistake i feel like but
you know
these points add up these half a point
they do
but i think sort of more importantly
fabi generally has a very good score
against resident has been doing very
well against alireza and i think you
know he would have liked to continue the
dominance right you know he he won he
beat the wrestler in the rapid if he
bits him with black
uh in the first blitz game uh
from a position he had and as well
we we can't really overstate just how
bad his position was straight out of the
opening it was horrendous uh
that just you know it gives you
additional confidence it's just very
good to you know continue beating a
player you will clearly be right play
you know he'll clearly be playing
against for the next 10 years years and
years to come as viktor korchner
famously said beat them while they're
young
so why is ali reza by himself with
everybody else chatting with each other
and he seems to be just is it the
generation
by himself
these are the
the olds
these are the olds and here's the
young's
uh on our uh opening uh
start of the show um the voice over
veteran sam shanklin you took offense i
i i i i it was a very very liberal use
of the word veteran
and you're saying wait a minute sam's 30
years old what does that make me yeah
and then i immediately offered a
dinosaur
i said well i'm fossil fuel
nice and nice um well uh let's take a
look at the upcoming round six bearings
if you don't mind uh let's do that
i'm curious what you think our marquee
match-up for this round has got to be uh
so we have karwani
shonda mangus nakamura vashiela graf
and ferocious
it has to be either the hikaru game or
the ferocious game we haven't watched oh
actually just watched i would say
yeah let's take let's take icaru right
okay uh hikaru uh
scored as i understand it four out of
five he's on four out of five he's still
leading up the blitz section two draws
is that right christian yes yeah two
draws and uh mdl
uh chasing by a half a point uh
when we were looking at the rapid games
between nakamura and mvl i think they
had just played each other a ton of
times yeah uh their their their blitz
must also be
uh
pretty incredible right yeah i'm curious
because they had match-ups i think when
we get when we get these stats from uh
from our production team i have a
feeling they include rapid endless i
don't think
uh those steps are purely purely rapid
blitz i feel i feel like this is just
we're being corrected we are very very
diligent work by production because for
me extremely
for me there's sure yeah there's there's
a very easy way to separate classical
from the rapid and bleeds but rapid
employees generally gets bundled
together so yeah we appreciate you tom
and
and tumlets no we don't just a second
just speak for you
just speak for yourself on this one here
wait a minute wait a minute um and i was
looking through the games guys and it
does seem like jeffrey in this game
against mvl did miss quite a significant
chance to at least put some pressure on
his more experienced opponent and that
was after this move bishop to f5 rook to
e2 was the response and he played the
move knight to c2 rook d294 and then it
was just more or less an equal position
moving forward now now
what about bishop takes c2 why not take
with the bishop and with the tempo as
well at the same time do not allow white
to go rook to d2 and create those type
of
situations in the position
if you do play rook take c2 of course
after queen takes d1 this is just simply
game over you're going to have to take
back on d1 i pick up the exchange
exchange pawn up this is going to be a
losing end game you cannot do that so
what you have to do
is queen to c1 at least according to the
engines which is not an easy move to
make you could easily just go into the
end game which in fact after rook takes
uh d8 either this or the other one as
well probably this one because i do want
to keep control of the f7 square black
is upon up you will have to spend some
resources and some time to try to
potentially get back into the game and
get that pawn back so i definitely would
have favored black in this position of
course you can try to go a3 and say that
sure my knight cannot go back because
you're taking the bish pawn c2 but i
have this beautiful move bishop to g3
you take on b4 i take on c4 i don't take
the rook of course
because then it's just going to be two
pieces for a rook and probably a much
better end game for white but this
bishop on c4 not protected you will have
to move the rook i'm going to pick up
the pawn on b4 as well this would have
given black a winning position of course
i do believe that mvl faced with this
situation after bishop ac2 would have
found the right move queen to c1
nevertheless still an imbalanced
position after that and jeffrey could
have taken advantage of this situation
quite an intriguing game in that one but
i have to say mvl escaped in that game
sometimes you need a little bit of luck
christian as the players get started
with this
round six i think of uh
hikaru as being
a once in a generation
uh phenom in blitz he i i watched him as
a young boy i mean literally as a 10 12
14 year old growing up and even in those
uh let's say precocious years he was
quite
a blitz demon and
now
he streams and watching them stream and
share in his views i just think it
goes to show how extraordinary he is in
your
in your
let's say experience
who
and especially uh
did you equate as a
as a blitz phenom
like i think
i would like to slightly disagree with
this okay with this general i mean not
not about hikaru in particular but right
i think most of the players who are just
sort of good at chess generally uh
tend to be good at this good blitz
players and uh uh even people who you
might not necessarily associate with
like blitz prowess let's say anatoly
karpov i think many people will you know
think that you know very classical style
you know positional player more than a
wonderful blitz player yeah wazzup was
an absolute monster at blitz and uh i
mean in my generation like kramnik uh
kramnik has always been a unbelievably
strong blitz player how about
yeah
i played long long matches against
that's why
yeah i wanted
like late 90s early early 2000s on icc
we played we played like dozens and
dozens of games
uh so yeah i think you know
not taking anything away from hikari i
think what i want to say is hikaru is
just a very strong chess player right
and
yes perhaps he has some sort of unique
aptitude for this but
it's really not that surprising he's
just very very good at chess and it does
in most cases i think translate into
being
being a very good chess player right but
being a good chess player and being a
good blitz player this is somebody who's
ahead on the clock consistently who
who doesn't lose on time he keeps his
nerves he's resourceful it just like the
tactics seem like
to flow yeah i mean it's something for
me extraordinary he is he is very very
good of course
there is no question about it and uh
this is why this game is uh or sort of
so of such importance
in the context of this tournament
because he's playing as one of the
leaders if he wins this one uh this is
one of those you know points that count
double not only right not only is he
getting a point he's also knocking uh
knocking one rival yeah one of his
opponents and uh
they played this line in the rapid as
well and uh mvl was much worse out of
the opening because he tried he tried
being ambitious he tried kind of playing
a position with many pieces on the board
uh for this game mvl went for very very
early d65 liquidating into the send game
which generally speaking is supposed to
be completely safe like in most cases
and it looks i think it's completely
safe as well i mean i don't see any
any problems uh as far as black is
concerned in fact a
few moves from now
something good might happen with uh
black majority 94 is the only thing that
worries me ever so slightly if i look at
this from the black perspective 94 with
ideas of knight g5 on knight c5 the
issue with that is just to show
something on the board let's say we go
knight e4 i don't know i play some kind
of objects which is happening stupid
waiting with a6 which is actually
probably counterproductive don't play a6
okay he played b6 which probably is
smarter if you play knight g5 here yeah
my point is i can take
yep play f6 and g5
and this structure is so solid that you
know
there are very very few people in the
world who enjoy having the two bishops
against anything then either right and
even i'm not going to play my wife
right
so
yeah i think mvl is completely fine i
don't i don't know if uh
i would already start preferring this
for black i kind of briefly considered
whether i think uh this is already a bit
better
but i don't it's only it's oh yeah
you knew what i was trying to do
yeah i could see you i could see you
struggling clicking uh f6 f6 knight f2 i
mean you can definitely imagine uh black
being ever so slightly better with the
space i very much like that mvl played
h5 and h4 as a kind of first order of
urgency in this end game he put the ball
on h4 right just to gain as much space
as possible on the green side on the
king's side sort of maintain maintain
his uh his majority on the king's side
exactly this is still a safe end game
for white even let's say if you make a
move like h2h3 which you generally don't
want to be making because it completely
kills off your structure on the king's
side even those in games you don't lose
very often right but
yeah if anyone has made progress since
the end game appeared on our boards by
move 10 i think it's black i think it's
black yeah and uh christian is we're
kind of gone on into some just to give
you a knuckle mastery what's happening
on some of the other games just to give
you an update it seems like fabiano is
building up quite a nice advantage
against jane pomnyashi out of the
opening this was the critical moment at
this point black played the movie nepomi
and she played move queen f6 and allowed
this transition into the end game which
is a tremendous end game for white
because you have so many weaknesses the
pawn on h6 the pawn on c7 is going to be
a weakness not only that but this knight
is also coming to g4 and that's going to
create a lot of havoc in your position
this one will be one that i will be
watching but let's get back to the main
i think he missed she takes h7 check
there but we've moved away uh yeah uh so
this
it's interesting that he took on d1 and
it's also very interesting that hikaru
chose to take with the knight i wonder
why not the because normally you want
your rooks on on open files i'm thinking
he has a dream
of occupying the f5 square one day with
his knight
maybe yeah it's it's some way away yet
and black can very easily stop it by
playing let's say bishop v6 and knight
e7 i also keep on looking at the move of
six five i think right mainly maybe he
is doing this whoa interesting knight d7
knight b8 d7 that wasn't on my radar
yeah bishop c one yeah clearly in
particular against knight b8 hikaru is
very heavily indicating that he wants to
play knight three knight of five now i
would almost say that that's like uh
um
a whistle yeah and now f5 from mvl one
yes followed by knight bg7 but then 93
that timing by blah blah blah playing f5
was not well done i was about to suggest
maybe we are trying to sacrifice a pawn
there but i think he will just just play
rook
h3 h3 okay um now i'm a little perplexed
because knight e3 look
you know to be yeah but i think he's
consistent he wants to be very very safe
rook of faith is a nice uh preparatory
move to uh you
you can't play knight c5 yet because the
opponent e5 is hanging so now you can
because you have to spend the tempo on
protecting the pawn on f5 but white as
yasser is correctly indicating he's
quite happily going to meet that with
bishop c4 and now
and go from there yeah right i'm not
sure i like what mvl has done yeah it
seems like he's loosened
up a bit i keep on wanting to play e4 f4
f4
but i don't think it works this is this
is not a you know this is not a middle
game with white with the white king on
g1 this is an end game so my
you know romantic pawn sacrifices are
probably a little bit too romantic
yeah time factor
uh let me let me take a look it's
disappeared about screens pretty that's
what i
mean i don't always get a chance to see
it yeah and there's our yeah and
camera's view as you were pointing out
here hikaru always always has to almost
always has a secure situation on the
clock under control and against somebody
by the way i have seen
uh mvl playing one minute blitz here at
the club
what uh yeah 94 will be played i think
kikara wants to go knight g2 but i think
king d7 still maintains the yeah very
very nicely done because you need the
bishop 27 protected and you need to have
uh have the rook have to check
as a resource officer to check of course
yeah so takes takes bishop e3 will be
played i'm pretty sure
uh and white i think is very safe but
with the king on e6 i don't think
um
runs
not too much risk
instead of instead of hp3 actually was
uh hikaru's choice
because he just wanted to stop e6
actually yeah sorry this is clever yeah
you can play rook f1 but it's a bit of
an empty gesture because it's not really
threatening much uh isn't this the time
i start to worry about bishops of the
same color positions start to put my
pawns on light squares or something like
b5
a6
the problem is the problem is b3 a6
bishop d4 and the pawn actually starts
hanging on e4 so he's gone rook f1 the
empty the empty somewhat empty jumps
somewhat empty gesture but yeah i think
i think mainly he just wants to provoke
bhp three and then play king e6 king of
five good point
um
which makes me think that uh hikaru
might play a4 and
a4 played just to keep the black king
for a moment honestly bishop f6 bishop
so this is how he wants to start holding
this position he put the rook on g1
saying you you can basically never take
on e4 because the trade of e4 g2 of
course is catastrophical for uh for
white uh and yeah that that rook or on
the back rank will just be a source of
very constantly a very very high
nuisance value and just to give you an
update jeffrey is winning is just
putting the finishing touches on the
struggling linear
apologies uh
three alarm fire bishop c one yeah
bishop c one bishop takes c3 bishop
bishop takes e3 i'm blessed to play rook
takes e4
g5 bishop
bishop c1 is considered an issue rook
takes e4 is my next move
i should be c3 rookie 4 anyway yeah why
is maybe better enough to bishop c1
that's what i was saying sorry sorry to
interrupt your christian no no no that
was a great point bishop to see one
might actually be yeah it has been
played and yeah all of this is on the
board of bishops you want me to see
rookie four
i think maybe mvl is still sort of okay
after bishop f6 rook g4 and then
but yeah this is now kind of uh
it's very unpleasant the result uh game
i would say yeah you're losing the g5
pawn and also very importantly uh hikaru
is attacking it from a very safe square
on g4 where his
his g2 pawn will be very safely
protected
i'm not sure if this is holdable for
black right like rook and games always
have very very heavy drawing tendencies
but this is going to be a very
problematic game for mvl at the very
least i think he missed that when he
played rook a1
he was prowling the first rank but it
just actually turned out to be a
tactical nuance he's missed i think i
think he got slightly over optimistic he
could have chosen pretty much any other
square
right right doesn't get locked out and i
think he would have been okay but
um i don't know if he is okay at all
because
uh white basically puts the rook on g4
and then starts threatening to
actually you might ali just won his game
against sam chandler
big result maintaining quite a
furious pace
yeah and in particular if we if we look
at this position and we recognize that
uh mvl can only lose uh and vl obviously
is not really playing for a win here in
is creating some separation between him
and the other content absolutely yeah so
something like check on c4 rook takes h4
and then rook to g4 put the rook on g3
and peter
h and then start running towards the
other yeah this would be a very solid
setup with the with the rook on g with
rogue specifically on g3 supporting the
pawn on b3
i is it winning christian uh how do
how are our engines it's just evaluation
i don't think it's winning no no the
engines are saying something along the
lines of plus 1.3 and that generally
means that you're not winning this one
it's probably yeah those affiliations
probably mean drawing in
in actual chess parlance but
yeah it's not a fun draw to be making
yeah rook g4 yeah take take take take
play rookie specifically what yazar is
saying it's very very important to have
your rook on the third exactly so that
there is no immediate count to play
against the pawn on b3 it sometimes
becomes a race but i think black
probably is yeah he's done he's doing it
by a slightly different move order but
it's the same idea yeah put the rook on
g3 now you want to with your king cross
over towards the h-pawn and try to
escort it
escort your h-pawn while keeping the
pawn on b3 points my issue with this is
that i would like right now to play king
whoa rook g5 check what are we doing
oh no big blunder by mvl oh
and i was about to say yeah yeah
actually jan did improve quite
significantly but it's still not in
not an automatic draw you make here
although yeah this is a much much better
position than
anything he's whoa okay let's not
blunder any mates by the way guys we
have real quick decisive games
is just a very very safe draw for young
young gets away with one for sure he was
in a lot of trouble in this in this game
yeah this is just very very safe draw
truly that yeah
just bishop yeah i don't think they are
like
i like john's making sure that he's not
losing his c
he doesn't go after the gym
yeah nobody's interested we don't want
to blunder
nobody's
and as you say ali reza did beat sam
shanklin sam hamming great um
rapids not so great
and yeah and they're here
by the way it was a whitewash four wins
but all with the white pieces and what
were they christian well actually this
game between firuja and shankland could
have went the other way around because
at this point ferocious was indeed
building a nice advantage the bishop g2
is a tremendous piece putting a lot of
pressure on the square d5 and this is
what he was focusing on the pawn
structure on the queen side and the
center now he played the move e4 a bit
prematurely because now black had a
tremendous opportunity of course if you
take on e4 which was played in the game
after knight to c4 your structure is
going to be falling not only that but
you don't have time to defend the pawn
with the move f5 now i have time to take
on d6 bishop returns to f4 the rook on
b8 is going to be lost and you can
pretty much resign but what he could
have done shanklin that is was to play
this move f6 first now i do believe that
he saw this move and he uh rejected it
because of the idea that after f4 you
can not take on e5 take and open up the
f5 after bishop to c7
first of all probably e takes d5 is a
move as well but after queen to f2
you're going to get completely destroyed
on the king side bishop to e6 to defend
the checkmate via f7 but there's another
checkmate coming queen to f6 queen to g7
this is game over finito but the problem
is that after f6 with the inclusion of
f6 and f4 the bishop doesn't have a way
to return home anymore so what i can do
is take on e4 right now you no longer
have time to take on c4 because of
knight to f5 the bishop is lost right
now not only that i'm also defending
with my rook the pawn on e4 this would
have been a tremendous opportunity for
sam shanklin to get back into the game
maybe even be better in this one he
missed this one and unfortunately for
him after this it was just pretty much
all she wrote his position was just too
weak on this side now let's take a look
at what jeffrey versus dominguez um was
all about and that one
i have to say dominguez is just simply
struggling in this event jeffrey very
smartly chose this idea with queen takes
d4 queen to d3 let's just get a game
let's get a slow game uh very balanced
position nevertheless you are as black
having to tend with a couple of
weaknesses in your position and this is
exactly what happened it's an easy game
for white and black will have to find
the right moves i have a space advantage
on the queen's side and after the move
e6 take on e6 rook takes c6 i also have
a weakness to play with and that is the
weakness on d6 it would have been a long
game
if not for this big mistake queen to h4
and after bishop to g4 well
unfortunately your queen is trapped of
course not bishop to g5 first because i
still have uh some ways to go on this uh
file the queen to e4 would have just
been okay for black the problem is i can
start with the move bishop to g4 close
the action of the queen on the fourth
rank you have to move the rook or you
can play the move f5 but unfortunately
after bishop to g5 your queen is trapped
big big big uh win for jeffrey who
actually is stringing uh quite a few
victories together i have a feeling and
he's close to the top right now
thank you for that christian uh
uh let's take a look at the farouza show
here as ali reza is
off to the races and he's doing it very
nicely peter yeah he's playing a very
solid tournament uh
in the last day of the croatia rapid and
blitz i think he scored eight out of
nine on that day uh wow we're not you
know he's not uh a stranger to really
really spectacular days of blitz but
considering he led
after the rapid a very very solid plus
two that you see on your screen right
now with four draws and a couple of wins
bookending the uh the draws there he has
a very healthy lead over the field here
you see you see one and a half for four
out of six in second place in the blitz
tournament behind hikaru uh who is on
five out of six and is currently in
clear fifth
so you predicted as christians
christian's prediction has already come
true and now yours will he make it to
the top three but jeffrey uh looking
pretty good as well
with matching ali raza with four out of
six
thus far
uh as we get ready for our break i was
about to say we're gonna take a look at
the bearings no no not yet we're just
gonna take a quick break and we'll see
you on the other side see you then
[Music]
hey st louis the ascension charity
classic presented by emerson is back
this september don't miss the excitement
when the pga tour champions best compete
again all for charity september 9th
through the 11th at norwood hills
country club pro-am spots hospitality
packages vip tickets and more available
now at ascensioncharityclassic.com
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
united states
the st louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant central west end has
established itself as a premier global
destination for chess and is comprised
of two unique non-profit institutions
the chess club and scholastic center of
st louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays host to
all major tournaments including the us
chess championships and the sinkfield
cup one of the strongest chess
tournaments globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries led by an expert
commentary team of grand masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess with a specific focus on
bringing the benefits of chess to
children throughout the st louis area
research shows children who play chess
exhibit improved analytical skills and
increased confidence the chess club is
highly engaged with the local community
bringing scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 schools providing hundreds
of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club is the world chess hall of
fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the u.s and world chess halls
of faith
cutting-edge exhibitions feature rare
historic chess artifacts paired with
world-class art innovative programming
explores the intersection of chess art
and culture
visitors can enjoy interactive programs
designed around the exhibitions and
monthly music in the galleries
the world chess hall of fame is nothing
you expect
greece and a premier gift shop highlight
the culture history and creativity
behind the game come visit play chess
leave enriched to learn more about the
st louis chess campus visit
stlchestcampus.org
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the final third of the
day three more rounds of blitz to go and
these are your standings with alireza
very comfortable there on 15 out of what
is what 24 points i assume yep
and then mvl a full point and a half
behind him jeffrey in clear third on 13
out of 24 uh yannibon machine clear
fourth and hikaru nakamura in clear
fifth already with five out of six in
the blitz tournament should say just
what the doctor ordered absolutely after
yesterday's
final game in particular against fabi in
the rapid he which he lost boy was he
upset and the pairings for the upcoming
round seven let's take a look yeah uh
sam shackleton is playing against fabi
uh shahir is playing against star leader
ali raza faroja mbl iranian dominguez
nakamura and nippon mishi is playing
against jeffrey chong we're probably
going to watch ali reza we haven't
watched him in a bit and he is after all
kind of running away with the tournament
so maybe it's
it's high time we returned to watching
the the flower shirt and uh for shakri i
apologize but as you were going down
that listing of current standings how is
he doing in the blitz in particular uh
if yeah i don't keep enough of the
enough records to tell you that without
tom trump showing me the graphics and i
just before we went back on air kind of
slacked him off so i don't think he will
show me the ground uh there we are
most forgiving he's a very very
forgiving person yeah uh
is actually kind of kind of back uh back
below
the water line yeah minus one in the
blitz and with his 50 in the rapid this
is
minus one overall yeah eleven and a half
out of twenty four
uh
definitely one of the moments of the day
for me so far yeah
playing king a6 with knight on c7 and
then both of them just bursting out in
love
exactly uh christian for you why is this
young man ali raza why is he doing so
well is it this consistency
what is it why is he uh
no i think he's successful so he was
used to playing a lot of chess uh before
i think it was the middle of 2021 he was
playing a ridiculous amount of games got
to 2800 plus and then stopped for a few
months quite a few months actually i
think five of them before the candidates
preparation resumed and after the
candidates which he performed subpar
according to his standards
it seems like he just doesn't have as
much weight on his shoulders anymore and
he can just play as much chest as
possible he's a young man he has the
energy he has the passion to play as
many games as uh needed over the year
and i think this is what he's doing
right now he's just enjoying playing
chess and he's a very dangerous young
man whenever he does that
absolutely and i want to point out that
there is a very very clear kind of a
battle of two schools of chess in this
game the sideway sideways knighters and
the the forward nighters right
i see the forward knighters on one side
yeah but the side and the sideway
neither is on the other side i'm a
sideways knighter i'm a i'm a very much
a forward knife forward yes
um man i'm in a minority
that's hurtful
um
one of the things even though you
mentioned that uh not such a successful
candidates
oftentimes you go to the candidates
tournament you don't get to play a lot
of your preparation but you get to use
it nicely in the ensuing months
that's something you you said he took a
long break
he didn't play chess for like five or
six yeah almost half a year he he won
the grand swiss he had this fantastic
result in the european teams and then he
went into some kind of hibernation and
nobody nobody saw him for like half a
year until um
bucharest not that nobody saw him but
nobody saw him online either and he used
to be online every single day playing
like 200 uh bullet games against the car
or something along those lines he did
not play unless he played under under a
pseudonym uh he did not play any games
online either interesting so i just kind
of went into a pause mode and maybe
study mode what do we have right now uh
in this game between uh shaq and
farrugia what's yeah this is a
kind of a vienna
ragosa mix it's more of a regulation i
don't know why i mean it briefly
threatened to be of vienna and then went
back on its ward uh
i thought this was one of the quieter
lines of the regulation but honestly
nobody should trust anything i say about
this opening i have no clue what i'm
talking about
and
it it
no longer really looks very quiet it
looks like a very very concrete position
you can play queen takes d4 of course
which is probably only actually on the
safer side because it allows black to
castle and then hit this queen with
knight g6
probably an issue with the bishop she
should take six maybe or something yeah
i was going to go queen takes d4 i'm
pawn hunting queen takes d4 castles
this might not work though because
bishop b6 i will take on a6 with my
bishop and i will play knight c6 and i'm
not sure you will find it comfortable
you have to play queen a4 i think
everything else loses the beast i play
b5 you have to play queen sitsu
everything else loses a piece
and now knight before bishop d5 all
those kinds of moves look kind of kind
of not
happy camper anymore and it feels like
we okay and uh huh i think i've seen
this before but i can't remember very
cute idea shown there by uh shahriar he
played queen a4 check
after 25
yep knight c6 and
uh uh quintet okay
yeah just took on before another choice
for black is you can take the queen on
before allow this endgame of 96 check
you will be slightly worse but perhaps
it's not a tragedy i'm not sure it's
actually it could be very pleasant or it
could be a minor issue or you can play
queen takes e4 which is what he did yeah
and now bishop b5 blitzed out by
uh shakhriar and uh
if black could castle easily here black
would of course be completely fine but
white is basing much of
much of his play on the fact
on the fact that the the queen on before
is taking away squares from
the king from the king on on e8 bishop
bishop takes e6 played yeah okay
okay i'm taking everything back if this
is the best we have here
yeah this probably is not going to be a
very exciting game in fact i would
suggest we probably unless he plays
something like queen g6 here okay then
we we have to stay because he's
basically saying okay i'm around i'm
still
uh hanging with you
and this is actually a very good choice
because white
is because of the weakness on g2
white is constantly one like you you
can't play knight t5 comfortably and if
you can't play 95 comfortably uh the
bishop of six is just stronger than
knight on f3 all of these end games all
of these end games will be a bit better
for black simply so if i play for
example a move like queen
i kind of regret that i don't have my
pawn on h3 already
it's not much it's not much but
definitely not suffering yeah definitely
a little bit better for black and
alireza recognizing that uh decides that
there's absolutely no reason for him to
give shakira a comfortable draw okay and
goes queen g6 and shah is actually deep
in the tank trying to choose between
okay he goes knight h4 i was again not a
comfortable choice to be sure yeah
specifically because queen g5 and i'm
not sure what the follow-up is because
yeah we've kind of misplaced our knight
we can't really bring it back very
comfortably
no because neither three bishop takes f3
wins a full piece queen of four
both queen takes a four and even keeping
everything as is and asking why to take
on g5 is also very pleasant for black
exactly
i was thinking you wanted to do induce
a5 and i couldn't understand why yeah
i'm a businessman i'm a bit surprised by
this i thought queen of four like it's
not fun but i thought queen of four was
playable i'm much less sure about this
yeah well i mean i meant earlier than
the previous movie not knight h4 yeah
yeah that was a strange sequence so i
don't like at all even let's say we take
on a four we go king e7 how do you bring
that knight back without spending a ton
of time on that
actually takes takes g5 black has got
borderline winning or something no takes
takes g5 agreed hang on this is just bad
you have to play knight of three i will
take and like this recording is
not happiness
i mean you you occasionally don't lose
it but
okay but you're very very happy if you
do escape
what is he doing
what is he doing uh shaq uh really
seizing the defensive here right out of
here i mean focusing g3 looked ugly but
i mean not exactly better than this not
as ugly as this yeah yeah i'm very
surprised by this so what what peter is
saying is right about this
point white is already in a little bit
of trouble but if he goes queen f4 queen
g3 and then a quickly knight e4 we're
trying to play 95 or 94 whichever one
will be allowed to yes and we're still a
bit worse but it's not not life and
death and but this is not nice and by
the way he did take he didn't play g5 he
played rook g8 he played king
h7 g1 yeah and rook d-8
uh it's interesting that he is allowing
g3 i mean g3 is still not a very
pleasant move to make but at least we
don't get our structure completely
destroyed the bishop will land on f3 and
you don't have to give up the d-file too
yeah this is but i don't have another
suggestion other than knight f3 which is
your triplets yeah it's just just truly
horrible
but okay as bad as that is i think i
would prefer that in allowing the bishop
on f3 he has played g3 he is inviting g5
yeah takes two you don't take first
maybe go knight without taking actually
knight to g2 immediately yeah it was
still bishop f3 this is what i was
fearful yeah this is going to continue
being extremely extremely horrible for
what and he's done that g5 and here we
go bishop f3 putting the question to the
rook
yeah this is just
i don't know what to even choose maybe
we take on d8 take on g5 and play h4 and
pretend we have some counter play but i
mean
guess what
uh
that's his pretense
yeah but gah simply knight takes h4
bishop c6 yes we've improved a little
bit but the rook will be on d2 in a
moment
and that bishop will uh be at its uh
maximum glory if you will absolutely
disgusting yeah and by the way guys
hikaru is going down against dominguez
ooh
lanier who was uh fading fading fast
yeah he's on
a half a point out of six so far but he
has a fantastic position against hikaru
yeah so not dead yet but about as good a
position as you can get by move 20.
that's the problem with this field no
matter who's doing badly they're capable
of beating anybody
at any given moment by the way you just
said the rook will land on d2 this is
actually an improvement for white i i
really wonder why i mean i understand
why he didn't want to you know
liquidate into a very technical end game
this is slightly more fun with a very
beautiful bishop against a very passive
knight but this is four against four the
knight will now finally have a decent
square on e3 with the knight only three
maybe i can try you know smoking your
rook out with like knight c4 knight e3
knight t493
or perhaps king of one king e1
let me just uh refresh yeah we haven't
we okay let's do that where am i i'm
over here i'm going to go
up one
gotcha
uh you're saying 93. yeah then i will
come to e3 and then i will you know if i
manage to drive the rook away from d2
most of my problems are actually
actually gone i want to play bishop f3
obviously and b4 b5 pardon me mm-hmm
trying to post
well b5 immediately yeah i want to keep
this rook as passively
that changes yeah this takes away all
hopes of ever playing knight c4 but it
does put our our pawns on the correct
colored color color squares because it
will be much much harder to hunt them
down with the bishop being
true the opposite persuasion
hmm
so much so i'm almost beginning to
double guess this move uh b5 there maybe
you could have started with a5 yes yes
yes yes
um it's okay it's still very unpleasant
though because you play knight e3 the
bishop lands on f3 and you still have
very very little in the way of you know
proactive moves
rook d3
sort of inviting knight f4 and then what
rook c3 rook c3 will b3 where where do
we want to put that piece
yeah i would assume i think he just
basically wants to make sure the rook on
a1 doesn't leave right
trying to tie your opponent up
strategically yeah great
great ideas f a5 yeah a 5v5 f4 would be
like the knight on e3 is a very good
piece if you can move it away even at
the cost of trading a pair of pawns it
would be extremely useful for black to
be able to push to f4 but you have to
prepare it yet the pawn five is hanging
so yeah
you have to spend some time preparing it
i was a little surprised
by the king d6 decision i thought you
might play f5 king f6 e5 and so forth
king of one and the point is if you play
bishop three i have a three a four which
is why he hasn't played it he's played
rook b3
and that's the three this is really this
really doesn't look as horrible as all
that you can play rookie one check
interesting what is he intending after
yell just go back or
also why did we go to e5 maybe it's not
that bad yeah i thought the king was
actually yeah
before kind of inviting f3 ah okay is
also in two seconds which is very
relevant i realized
why some of these things are happening
yeah f4 without the yeah without the
preparation with the 6v he's allowed a4
shock is actually sort of explicit i
mean a6 is quite strong now
but why he didn't just start with a6
that would have stopped a4 altogether
was premature he's winning the bottom
before anyway he can play bishop f3 or
king of three now uh creating mating
threats against two seconds will be very
unpleasant
also wins the pawn on b4 i guess well
bishop f3 i'm assuming
yeah thinking i thinking of three
stronger ones yeah rugby one kingdom
yeah no
yeah rock takes after rook c2 is going
to be made careful not yet not yet mate
but uh this uh almost one second how
many how much time that was that was
played on two seconds on two
yeah it looks like black should just be
completely winning but yeah maybe
roxanna is six actually yeah roxy six is
very strong knight c3 i like less
actually you have bishop c2 bishop
bishop d3 is very very tasty that's a
very nice set of bishop to c4 and now
rook c2 wins the piece yeah yeah he's
won the game
nicely done by alireza wow uh in the
meantime hikaru is at the very least
okay i mean i thought he was completely
fine but
uh but i'm not so i've got a game
between sam shanklin and fabian yeah sam
was completely winning i think at some
point and now he might lose because
there's his passer on a3 which i don't
know how it survived and got there
and it's a very good very good passer
absolutely looks like mvl has been the
clocks
the clocks between these uh yeah both
are on under 10 seconds so under 10
seconds yeah rook bb3 finally rendered
which will cost which will cost sam the
whoa still bishop c5 is very strong
because
yeah a2 probably wins a piece as s5b no
no rook takes c7 let's not allow rook
take c7 that would that might be a
perpetrator yeah no it's actually a mate
it's not oh geez not even a perpetual
yeah is just completely winning now the
eight pawn will quinn
rookie three yeah rook c3 was strong but
yeah just d3 you have two runners yeah
with with two of them running you kind
of always get their british pretty
pretty much here which would be four and
now
little wins a piss yeah yep
there we go well done fabi
wow uh this maybe concludes the round
that was
there was some bloodshed in this round
wasn't there because jeffrey lost to
that boat jeffrey was
uh up there in third place i believe
five decisive games fantastic yeah
but what happened to here carl
just flagged oh
dominguez
oh my gosh over to you christian we were
told that uh
hikaru was in desperate sha
he was he was indeed this was the
position queen to e6 just simply do not
exchange the queens play the move knight
to c4 all of black's pieces are tied
down to the defense and my plan is
straightforward i just go a5 a6 a7 if i
manage to put the pawn on a7 the game is
over so keep the queens on the board
keep uh the king under threat this would
have won the game for white at least
given him a tremendous advantage he did
not do that he played queen takes c6 and
now he's starting to feel like black is
slowly but surely getting back into the
game and once you cut down the action of
the bishop on e3 with the move c5
stabilized by the knight on e6 now
you're going to be able to corral the
pawn on b6 and actually get tremendous
compensation and this is exactly what
happened and it does feel like rook to
a7 was
made one second or maybe a couple of
seconds too late because this was it
game over after rook to a7 he flagged
incredible result in this one i have to
say i was looking at the game between um
mvl and aronian as well and aromian was
doing more or less okay
this was the critical moment b4 rook to
8 this was a berlin by the way queen to
d6 f uh b5 bishop to b7 queen to f4
queen to d8 g3 knight to g7 bishop to a3
and this was the critical uh miss he
played the move f5 the problem after f5
is that you're giving away too many dark
squares i'm going to go queen to e5
which he did the king becomes extremely
weak followed by bishop to h6 you're not
going to be able to survive as we will
see in just a second what he should have
done was to freeze a white species with
this move rook to a2 now the queen is
tied down to the defense of the bishop
at d2 if you try to shy away from that
with the move uh bishop to c1 i'm going
to follow that bishop rook to a1 and now
you're going to have some more resources
tied down to the defense of the bishop
on c1 still it feels from a practical
perspective that maybe white is slightly
better but black is definitely in this
game he did not do that he played the
move f5 and he got punished very quickly
after queen to e5 bishop to f3 and this
was the position rook to f8 queen to d6
rook to e8 the final mistake and this is
just a checkmate in two moves rook takes
c8 uh
there was just no need even for rook
takes eight i would assume he played
rookie eight realized that he's getting
checkmate uh chuck made it in uh two
moves after tasty eight knight xc8 queen
to f8 and just simply resigned so quite
an intriguing one as well and the final
one that we did not see was the one
between nepo and jeffrey sean jeffrey
was on a roll going into this round but
unfortunately for him he faced a very
dangerous nepo an english opening and
this was a critical moment knight to c3
queen to d8 d5 very nicely and precisely
played by nepo i have to say i was
following it with the engine and he was
playing the best moves in the position
and this is the one that i really like
queen to e1
a very hidden and nuanced move after
queen to e1 knight d4 seems like the
right approach the problem is that after
knight takes e4 this goes into a very
forced line with a queen on d2 this
queen would have been able to take on d2
knight takes d2 and black would have won
a piece after knight takes c2 but with
the queen on e1 we have this variation
fourth variation root ac one you do pick
up the piece but i have this check
knight to f6 bishop takes f6 rook to e8
and we transition into this winning
endgame for white despite the fact that
i have two pieces for the rook and a
pawn this is the problem the bishop c8
the pin on the eighth rank is just going
to be so difficult to get rid of and
this is exactly what happened rook to h8
knight to d4 rook to c7 all of my pieces
are extremely active and putting a lot
of pressure on black's position and b5
was the final mistake because after rook
to d8 there's no way to defend the
knight on d6 you can go knight to f5 but
then i'm just simply going to follow it
up with g4 you cannot move the knight
you lose the knight on d6 and this was
all she wrote he took on a4 take on a4
rook to b8 h4 and uh after rook takes a
5 rook takes d6 or d8 this is just a
very sad situation for a black and he
was never able to recover from it very
very intriguing and very bloody round i
have to say in this seventh round at the
saint louis rapids thank you christian
which leads to these current standings
after seven rounds of blitz uh peter
yeah hikaru and six out of seven
eurozone five out of seven
uh yanipon mishi and fabiano caruana in
tight tied for third in the blitz
tournament on four and a half out of
seven but our overall standings are
alireza is very safely up top uh mbl
sort of continuing the pace with one of
one and a half point behind uh jan is
now in clear third on thirteen and a
half and then uh hicary and jeffrey uh
both on 13 uh half a point off the
pedestal uh finish and hikaru is playing
against
uh jannan uh in the next round so that's
that could be a very
nice
uh marquee
interestingly it actually gets pipped
because we have ferocious versus
maxim oh which has the french derby
number two uh that has to be a marquee
match-up by the way i mean carlo said
come on guys i need a little help i'll
i'll take my six out of seven somebody
please stop ferugia
i mean there's still a three-point gap
between him and uh
um and uh the leaders but he but
nanaka got gifted yeah he did get a very
huge dollop uh dollop of help there by
by i mean i'm still i'm still slightly
linear is one of the strongest sort of
classic classical not in the way of time
control but in the sort of understanding
of chess and the way he puts pieces on
correct squares right throughout his
career queen takes e6 kind of makes my
own justified yeah like i don't
understand how how linear in particular
would ever bring that knight on the face
and just towards the end
linear dominguez a former world blitz
champion
uh by the way out of the how many games
seven times so it was 35 years we got
24.
that's the size that's a large number
yeah i mean after we were going on the
steady diet of one decisive game per
round in the rapids that is
day three we had the three
decisive games
things are getting bloody uh christian
the guys are beginning to swing for the
fences oh absolutely and as anticipated
naka is showing his stuff in the faster
time controls i have to say i'm mightily
impressed with what he's doing right now
the pineapple shirt power
is showing today look at that oh my
goodness what a score line only two
draws no defeats and five
victories incredible very very
impressive in the pacific northwest from
seattle we had the pineapple express
that's the jet stream from hawaii to
british columbia the pineapple express
so when you said that that triggered
i've seen the movie yeah wow
very impressive i said six and a half
out of nine and he's on six out of seven
so i was underselling it by a margin
but yeah you you do need occasionally to
for your opponents to perhaps not play
there for instance yeah yeah
lanier is having a day to absolutely try
to forget i don't know i don't know how
you like i'm saying try because it will
kind of stick with you and yeah as you
very correctly pointed out as a former
world champion in this game precisely uh
he won but actually kind of
interestingly especially considering
that lanier is these days of seemingly a
very slow player who absolutely needs
increment yes the tournament he won in
kazakhstan in 20 i want to say 12 well
was a 5-0
really that was i played in it oh very
strange yeah that was that was i i
played it i didn't do it i didn't do
horribly but i didn't do too well and
lanier just crashed and he kept on
flagging people
at the end
and i don't mean by playing you know
king against stroke right in messi maybe
some of some of the positions he had may
have been bad
but he just played with incredible speed
and also managing to sort of blunder
fewer pieces than his opponents exactly
i'm pretty sure that was a five of five
zero tournament uh the one the one he
won wow well one thing about linear that
i remember vividly is his match at the
champions showdown against wesley saw in
which both of other players actually
left their blood
on the clock oh yeah they were literal
blood on the clock and they were so fast
and linear was extremely fast he's not
showing that speed in this tournament
not at all just to give you kind of an
idea of what happened in this game
between sam shanklin and fabiano because
shanklin was completely dominating this
one uh from out of the gates he was just
completely winning great preparation uh
fabiano played the czevezhikov he has
not essayed this in his previous rounds
maybe a new try from fabiano and he got
himself in trouble and this is exactly
the position in which uh shangri-la
should have just simply dominated he did
not do that king to g2 was already the
wrong direction what he was supposed to
do is take advantage of the fact that
the king is so weak and try to bring
more resources into the game c6 followed
by rook to c5 rook to f5 maybe put a
pawn on c7 as well followed by rook to
c6 is just so dominating and black
doesn't have any um slimmer of an edge
or a compensation via the d pawn he
doesn't have that he doesn't see that he
played too slowly knight to h5 bishop to
h8 king to g2 a5 okay give me some more
tempes please give me some more tempest
so i can go a4 okay i'll give you some
more tempest queen to g4 king to f8
queen to f3 what how can you play like
this right that's great i feel like
you're supposed to checkmate or at least
find a way to bring more resources
around the black weakened king and you
play quinji for queen f3 that cannot be
good after a4
queen takes f3 and the trade of the
queens black finally managed to get back
into the game and actually manage to
take full advantage of this pawn on a4
and uh deliver a victory for faviano a
huge victory for fabiano by the way who
needed this to stay in contention
absolutely he did and even that position
looks great for white a big big mess
indeed uh by sam shanklin i wanted to
say that in the rapid
when farouza and mvl
uh
paired off against each other that was a
that was a non-game yeah that's what i
wanted i don't think i don't think it
will be a non-game in blitz i feel like
they both enjoy playing blitz a little
bit too much but we have to be on the
lookout but we have a very very
clear-cut second favorite to switch to
if this once again becomes a burden that
is uh
yeah
and we we lied about the yearling year
world won the world blitz in 2008
and since you were there and apparently
i took bronze yeah
respect peter
and just to remind everybody tomorrow is
the end of the event we'll have again
uh colors reversed round robin blitz i
have nine games and in case of a tie
there will be a tie breaker
and as usual our coverage begins at the
same time
we got in that yeah good that looks
fantastic yeah let's uh
let's get some some some moves too hot
too hot to handle
players getting ready for this is it
round eight right now yeah it is late
and we can see is that hikaru all the
way
at the end yeah that's definitely over
there yeah sitting
there
already already he's already at his
boards
although very focused today ricardo i
have to say
he knows he needs a big day to get back
into uh
yeah if he wins this game he's probably
in the top three yeah yeah we want to
really be careful because again winning
on
time
in a worse position where
again you've been suffering mostly
yeah but that was a real
real um gift
by uh lanier there
and as you say it's a it's a day you you
just assume quickly forget
how do you do that i i don't know i it's
it's going like for me it's always been
extremely difficult to uh just
completely tune out bad days exactly
sometimes i deal with it better
sometimes worth but worse but it's uh
it's not something i've ever perfected i
love the quote by magnus carlson so a
young boy
asked magnus in norway
you know
when did you stop crying after a loss
magnus said who said i stopped crying
after i lost
yeah the boy felt so much better about
himself and once again i don't think
he's like i don't think he's trying to
make the young boy feel better no no i
think he's very very genuine about this
i definitely definitely can relate here
how do you deal with a loss uh
christian yes sir i haven't played chess
in three years
i'm an activist i don't know how it
feels to play chess anymore but i have
to say that i i'm pretty bad with taking
losses if i have a bad tournament i have
a hard time recovering generally if the
tournament starts well then i'm probably
going to have a decent tournament if it
doesn't i have a very very difficult
time
coming back into the tournament why what
i tell my uh students for example is
just keep things in perspective but it's
easier said than done yeah yeah i i some
of my
horriblest binges horrible list well
yeah i know it's underway yeah
awful you know tv show binges have come
from
from you know playing a really really
horrible day a horrible game of chess i
mean yeah you just feel like yeah i'm
not i'm not getting asleep like
there's no point trying to sleep so
let's just watch like i don't know eight
episodes of something breaking bad
whatever whatever it is at the moment i
get it i get it i get it let's let's
like we watch the first two seasons of
boston legal or whatever that's actually
a good idea yeah
that's not a bad series i like boston
noodle as we're getting ready for our
all french derby here
uh
number one uh in in the lead ollie raza
on our left playing the white pieces
against and i think he's number three
versus number four
number one versus number two and number
three versus number four that's quite
around
definitely
and by the way this is a battle which
ended quite peacefully in the rapid time
control
with mvl forcing the draw in that berlin
yes situation
and as you can see i don't think we're
going to see the same thing yeah this
doesn't look there's no they've got game
voices on it right this doesn't look
like a draw yeah he's not returning the
favor for sure no
no
no this this feels like it's a game
and uh fabiano right now solidifying his
position as the number two best player
yeah let's let's actually uh check in
with this uh hikaru is probably on 2880
by this point yes 20 20 84 85 i already
checked wow
his 16 rating points away blitz rating
points from 2900.
that's uh
quite the achievement and there we go
around three more victories and he's
going to touch
that milestone
so no c4 by uh yeah interesting that he
brought him such success no reverse
sicilian against the sicilian specialist
right but he might actually play the
sicilian now no he he goes into an
actual proper english
uh the c4 c5 uh
yeah yeah and vl has played a bunch of
different things in this position e5 i
think
is the go-to yeah variation
and this is a very interesting turning
point because you can play e3 d4 which
leads to very very sharp very
interesting positions or you can play g3
and switch to
those things yeah yeah
now for me it's always been the g3 i've
enjoyed playing
those real maneuvering games but uh
e2 e3 uh
forces a more i want to say uh very much
dependent early clash but yeah not
anymore
quincy two is still an attempt to play a
somewhat waiting game you can make a
kind of a quiet move with black here i
think d5 would probably be a mistake
because that allows
uh a bunch of tactics like uh takes a
mission b5 even even 95 queen e4 might
win a pawn there
g6 is very playable now and with the
community of course you will find it
much harder to play d2g4
so um the combination of e3 and queen c2
makes sense when black has committed
itself to d5 i'm not quite sure about
this setup i think mvl is now very very
happily not playing the sicilian anymore
at least not for the time being yeah
maybe a3 yeah a3 is logical yeah e3 i'm
expecting a34
i i think he's gone bishop pizza judging
by the fact that he's already i know e3
bishop two yeah
yeah now that the bishop is already on
g7 we can go back to considering to play
d5 at least but i don't know if we still
need to we can go rookie 8 for now
ask white if you're worried about e4 i
guess if i before is never a threat um
but yeah and vl just says i will put the
pawn on d6
like if the knight was not on f6 if the
knight was only seven black would be
extremely high right oh absolutely
because that is sort of exactly the
setup you want right the reason alireza
is going for this is i think pretty much
that he provoked knight f6 and now black
has this strike structure where you
really really just like this knight 26
it's in a way
a little bit of your own play and so on
but it's a solid uh
solid position for
by the way
uh one of the reasons that uh black did
not play
an early bishop e6 is because he would
have played knight g5 and knight e4
absolutely and this is actually
well uh
a game with all the pieces on the board
yeah peter and uh
when you have a situation like this so
you're you're actually just fighting for
control of squares right
and in white's case are you thinking
about capturing no i think we i think
we're preserving this tension uh this
tension in the center for as long as
possible i like queen a4 24 and i also
think that what we're going to see uh
next
is probably something along the lines of
92 bishop f3
knight d2 and bishop f3
yeah it's it's useful to put it on b2
but i think in general the knight on f3
is not doing very much it probably goes
to d2 and then we are hinting at bishop
f3 we're hinting at knight d4 in some
positions
uh as for black
if you had time for it i would very
seriously would like to play knight h7f5
just to get more control in the center
then bring the knight back to f6 and
sort of go from there i'm not committing
to anything i just think the pawn on the
five would improve my position
but i think we never have i don't think
we we you ever have enough time for that
with well as predicted knight to d2 and
angling that to improve the prospects of
the bishop
is there anything to be said uh probably
not for i think captures in d5 i'm
trying to resolve the tension yeah i i'm
looking at this option in every single
position here as black if i you know if
i'm you're always calculated
if i'm in mvl shoes here this is the the
one change of structure that i'm
constantly trying to evaluate
but it's probably a bit early but rook
fg8 is definitely an indication that mvl
is also very interested in that
knight g4 i think we take i don't think
we are very worried about g takes e4
which is strange because i've always
liked these kinds well you don't have a
rook on c1 i think
very specifically i think i will
probably develop enough count to play
against opponent c4 just straight away
this is why i'm saying this
like maybe cb4 a b4 and knight e7 and i
will just snap on d5 when it appears
there but maybe it doesn't work
tactically because i will have a rook on
d7 so i will not be able to take with
the knight yeah maybe i'm wrong yeah and
we also disagree he goes knight g4
knight e8
okay
knight e4 knight e8 okay you were
talking about knight h7 and f5
that's very similar okay is it time oh
oh my queen is hanging
i can't yeah you're you're running out
of b
i've got to be careful that this knight
d4
doesn't uh play tricks on me yeah by the
way guys just to give you an update uh
nakamura is dominating his matchup
against yone pomyasi right now
he might be going to seven out of eight
that would be a good score
that would be what is known in the
business as a good scorer a good day at
the office wow
um
and we do have bishop f3
f5 and knight back to
d2 and the line does return to f6 no
no foul but i think once you play f5
you're not playing d5 anymore
less likely i i don't think it's
entirely ruled out but it's less likely
and bishop d5 is an interesting option
there by alireza doing this while the
bishop is still only six with a bishop
on f7 i think black very happily takes
with the knight yes but now taking with
the knight will cost you a piece
of the bishop take him with the bishop
you're less happy about so i think i
actually think i played i play bishop so
in any way yeah i want you to make the
i just like bishop 7 and then queen
takes f7 moving like all that yeah
just getting out of the dark yeah my my
reasoning for bishop 7 was king h7 still
doesn't create a threat of knight takes
you you wanted to create this threat
yeah once again i want to resolve that
tension i want to really kind of very
seriously ask white are we trading are
we not
tell me now tell me now tell me now now
would be the time to tell me yeah right
h7 doesn't do that job as well but i
understand the movie just keep moving
the king away from a somewhat open
diagonal to to not have to calculate
those things anymore the players seem to
have been moving takes things b5 i was
wondering about that the thing is
yes yeah the thing with this is uh like
after 97 do we actually we probably do
take when they said it's a bit weird
because the queen will be
sort of stuck can we calculate 97 sure
buy it let's do it 90 queen c7
i go rook e8 me the pawn yeah now here i
have to pause
loses because i go rogue db8 and 98 i
actually win the queen you have to play
queen b7 uh queen b6 loses because you
play rook gb8 and then 98.
ooh that's a that that's uh that's worth
a diagram so yeah i was interested but
mvl really wasn't so he went knight a5
already and i like in these types of
english positions uh english opening
positions you really just like putting
that on a5 so i would have gone queen a7
queen b7 yeah and then i can play d6 d65
and maybe i don't let you to play queen
of three this was my point yeah
okay but knight if i've played and
alireza goes e34 very understandably uh
blocking off yeah everything bishop g7
is going to be very difficult to
activate knight on a5 is kind of
horrible there were some kasparov karpov
of games like yes in the in the early
1980s matches which
won
kasparov one very very convincingly yes
you know i i like i like this game by
the reza so far i think it's a very very
sound
you know he's showing a very decent
uh grasp of what's happening here
white's absolute dream is that uh well i
was about to say knight takes pawn takes
white's absolute dream is that he would
get his bishop to c3 and his knight to
c4
and
maxine
recognizing that has played the move c5
c4 interesting pawn sacrifice
peter i'm not so sure that was a great
idea
well i mean he needs to do something he
is basically gambling on this being
somehow correct and you know landing the
knight on c4 it's horrible but i think
his position in general was just
horrible so can i take another pawn is
trying to get a gold membership in the
uh all right
about it
are we sure i think it's okay
followed by knight's c5 yeah but then i
have the c6 square so maybe i have a
move yeah but i don't have enough moves
i have i don't have a good move yeah
maybe f4 yeah
maybe f4 but yeah you don't need to the
the problem for black here is that but
he's thinking about it he's definitely
thinking about it i mean if if it works
it wins
so i mean there's every reason to
consider he took very seriously he took
it he's not okay he's a greedy young boy
yeah i i like this guy
he said give me uh give me the pawn by
the way uh
if
if mvl had the the chance to play knight
c5 h5 bishop h6 yeah his game
would improve
and this is why he played uh for this
sponsor
yeah
okay
this is two pawns sacrifice yeah we now
we go queen a4 queen c2 and now it's
time to
hurry hurry home scurry goodbye goodbye
and thanks for all the fish and things
of that nature exactly
so
there we go knight c5 knight takes e4
i'm not in i'm just one tempo shirt with
h5 which page six there yes you are 95.
if you take only four i take only four
and then i defend the pawn on c4 yeah
and i wanted to play h5 by so it's kind
of one move no it's not one move it's
two moves
oh
okay this is oh this is this is not
that's a bad sign that this is not going
to work yeah
that too one pawn sacrifice i might have
been supportive but no no
just keeping the king's side stabilized
stabilize everything and yeah mbl is
basically saying yes i'm two pawns down
but my position suddenly is kind of
solid i don't think he's ever dreaming
of me giving mate on the kingside or
anything stupid like that he just says i
have no weaknesses please find a way to
break this down but yeah two down
so down eventually eventually eraser
will find a way to go right it's
difficult to imagine how this doesn't
really get converted exactly exactly uh
again one of those nobody believes you
kind of thing
and look at him go he's got
um hello what is going on he um
he got enthusiastic as what happened
christian
[Music]
how do you defend the part on b6 not so
easy not so easy is it time for c5 yes
it is he thought it is time for c5 c5
queen c2 and knight f3 is that the
nintendo 4.
is the queen getting trapped it's if you
allow me to go knight f3 the queen is
definitely getting trapped yes indeed so
you probably have to go c4 right in the
meantime there has been a huge turn
around in the camaraderie bombing issue
game which looked like it was just over
and and now it looks also like it's over
only in the in in the opposite direction
it's actually
yeah chicago is in huge amounts of
trouble but we will stick with this one
because it's the excitement is
this is maybe this is maybe the best
position mvl has had all game
for a while and it's probably still lost
yeah right he's probably still lost
rook a3 let's round up the passer we can
also include h4 i think he's looking
yeah he three seconds though yeah like
he's he's cutting it a little bit close
i have to say rookie one and now d2 whoa
d2 and we win the pawn on h4 and vl
might survive this
this is amazing why didn't he just take
the pawn on d3 like he wanted to stop g5
g4 he went he thought he could have
absolutely everything wanted his cake
absolutely yeah
he wanted he wanted absolutely
everything still not close to surviving
because i have these rookies
why is still winning but as i said like
this is maybe the best we've had in
a long long time yeah
yeah and we go g5 g4 we like we pretend
we don't really pretend very
successfully pretend the problem is you
have to worry about 97. yeah we have to
worry about a lot of things there
whoa and of course hicaro did not win
lose but neither did nepo yeah he was
they made a draw yeah they made the draw
i'm solid i'm guessing they were
yeah
right now yes you're right you are
absolutely right now he gets what he's
done a va file right no i i kind of he
wants to go rookie five yeah this should
be an easy way
i i remember a game that that shaq won
with two connected past pawns which
maybe he should not
have
take another pawn yes that's a that's a
munch i think this is over guys
are we sure yeah we we're pretty yeah f3
but it doesn't do anything
and i'm still on the second hang on a
second but why don't you give a check
first yeah we should be playing g7 yeah
and that's probably good and he should
have done this quite a while ago yeah
that's probably that spells disaster you
have seven and then rook takes f3 rookie
three yeah just go well even gf and a
four or five yeah that's even better
yeah four or five in this nicely done
nicely spotted yeah
wow wow alireza continues winning and
hikaru continues running quite quite
pure
because on my screen there young had a
mate in 10.
a made in 10 a mate in 10 in a number of
ways by the looks of things
uh
i didn't i saw the 11 10. yeah
it did look
well let's see the end of that game
between acaro and yeah this position is
no longer winning shockingly the king on
te1 actually defends itself there are
not enough checks
i'm trying to get this absolutely
positioned absolutely amazing
there's a mate on oh geez
yeah i'm pretty sure he missed the fact
that knight c2 exists and suddenly there
is no follow-up and uh just perpetual oh
yeah he thought he was giving mate and
then he realized 92 exists and you the
only thing you have is
259.82 to avoid made on g7 yourself yeah
by the way are we seeing a slight smile
from nepo yeah i think
yeah i think he's smirking there a
little bit because he knows that
he is
yeah well i mean he also knows he was
completely utterly lost by 15. so you
know you can't you know he's i think
he's objective enough to realize that
yes i mean uh obviously i was winning
but i was also losing as well right well
i mean it's blitz the the advantage is
going to have big swings right christian
no absolutely and actually let's take a
look at how the advantages were swinging
in this game first of all uh hikaru
started once again with this c4 followed
by a3 maybe the english is definitely
entering the zeitgeist
after this tournament now let's take a
look after this move queen to e3 queen
takes c3 and just play the end game i
know it's going to be a worse end game
you're going to have to deal with the
majority of pawns on the king side
nevertheless that's going to be a much
easier place to defend then the
following queen to g6 this is a problem
after castle i'm taking over the
initiative and your pieces are out of
place especially this queen on g6 you're
going to have to spend a lot of
resources to try to create anything on
the queen side as black and let's uh go
to the moment after knight to d4 bishop
to c4 he took on f5 with the pawn simple
would have just been knight takes f5 of
course you cannot take with a rook on e5
because i have the move knight to e7
that would get some uh some material but
also queen to d4 queen to d4 attacks a
lot of pieces the [ __ ] pawn c4 the
knight on d7 the recon e5 also uh under
attack and you don't have the move
bishop to e6 because of knight to e7
which finishes the game so he missed
that opportunity he took with the g pawn
queen to h5 still feels completely
dominant from the white's perspective
nevertheless let's take a look when did
oh that was a big one knight takes c5
taking this poison pawn and allowing the
rook to get get in the game with
tremendous consequences which actually
happened knight to e4 bishop takes e6
even better than that would have been
knight takes c4 you cannot take with a
queen and place the queen on the light
squares because after bishop to d5 you
would lose that queen so you have to
take back with the pawn and i can just
simply continue with bishop to b3 pick
up the exchange and have a better
position unfortunately for him he did
not do that and let's take a look where
was the checkmate that you guys were
mentioning queen to d5 king to c3 b5
rook to c7 yeah queen a2 here is kind of
good queen it's not the only move but
yeah just playing queen a2 here it does
look
like i don't think anyone is surprised
that's a check coming yeah that's a pawn
with another check coming yeah this one
is just completely over this looks
done if you do try to go uh for the
checkmate yourself you get checkmated
first oh e3 that's an ouch
big game big swings in this one let's
take a look at what happened in the car
wanna versus jeffrey because let's not
uh forget this was number three versus
number four in uh this round a big big
matchup and fabiano opened up with the
london in a very strange london bishop
d3 bishop takes d3c takes a d3 and at
this point he already had a one minute
advantage on the clock quite a
significant edge i have to say knight to
e5
and this was the critical moment right
here
after queen takes b2
the position 13 seconds for a jeffrey
shong 33 seconds for fabiano the easy
way out is to just simply go rook to d7
and play this position he did not do
that he forgot that after queen takes b7
you are attacking the the rook but i can
defend that with the inter mezzo check
queen to c1 the king goes up now i pick
the rook not only that but i also defend
my own rook and actually jeffrey went on
and won a smooth end game after that not
only that you're losing the exchange
you're also being forced to trade off
the queens which is going to lead to a
very easy technical endgame for black
quite a big swing in that game as well
and let's take a look what we're looking
at in terms of standings after eight
rounds that's a dominating performance
that's a that's a two and a half lead
two and a half point lead there at the
top alireza is still in clear first of
course maxime despite not really he's on
uh
that was around eight he's on minus one
today minus one but still in clear
second and fourteen and half then jan
and jeffrey on fourteen uh points one
and hikaru is still not in the top three
it feels like uh christian will be the
more realistic prognosis seemingly
picaron 13 and hop there i said top five
just keep it there hikaru
and uh as we go on break before our
final game we have a feature for you we
asked the players
what attributes are necessary to be a
good rapid player as well as a good
blitz player here are their answers
[Music]
what are the three most important
attributes that make for a good rapid
blitz player
three attributes okay i mean i think
there's one certainly that stands above
the head and shoulders above the rest
which is certainly intuition the ability
to kind of intuitively sense a move
versus doing pure calculations and what
that means is just in a couple of
seconds you can sort of sense what the
options are and you just pick one based
on intuition as opposed to having to do
calculations um
that's the first one i think second one
is probably just general time management
again sort of it comes back to intuition
but sensing what moments to use the 15
20 seconds versus making a move
instantly
that's the second one and if there's a
third one i mean i don't know maybe it's
just confidence i can't really think of
a third one specifically it makes a huge
difference
i think number one would be
probably the instincts the gut feeling
second would be the calculation
and the third would be resilience
a good tactical vision
good openings and obviously good time
management because you need to always
um i mean ideally you should always be
ahead on the clock if you want to do
well in this tournament for me i would
probably put intuition as as the first
i think
if you can feel good moves you're going
to do really well
just because
yeah you really don't have much time to
sort of work everything out
i feel like the ability to
keep your nerves
would be
a close second for me
finally
maybe just
the experience factor i would say like
in general if you have more
games under your belt especially rapid
and blitz
you'll you'll know you'll sort of know
what works well if i knew maybe i would
would be a better rapper and blitz
player myself i've really brought my
classical chess up to be the absolute
being the world elite and one of the
best players in the world and rapid
blitz i'm good but it's been lagging
behind so i've been trying to get better
and hopefully this term will be an
opportunity to uh to improve further um
in general i think it's it's very good
instincts very quick tactical vision uh
for example if you see a tactic in two
seconds and i see it in three in
classical this just doesn't matter at
all but in blitz it's a huge advantage
so just having a very quick board vision
and uh and having extremely good
intuition and i think also having a more
narrow opening repertoire on knowing it
deeper helps a lot more uh making sure
that you can remember your stuff is is
very important because you can't think
oh uh i checked this a year ago what was
the move and spent four minutes thinking
about it it doesn't work interrupted but
it's the way it does in classical of
course
to play
fast
not mistakes
last one is big luck
and
just to not miss
big blunders
calculations and instincts like this
ability to
to play fast to to have a good flow
especially in blitz
the ability to you know
muddy waters to
complicate the game to play one more
move
which in classical will not matter so
much but you know epidemics it's
this opportunity like to be so resilient
that your opponent can
let you sleep sleep away because
with one and uh another you know tough
move of defense
at the end it can be frustrating uh
especially if you as your parents so
that's also very important and of course
keeping composure like um you know
because every especially in blitz you
get down to your last few seconds almost
every game so
there you really need like to be focused
on the game and
nothing else to keep your nubs
um yeah you have to be very sharp at all
the time so it's
um it's
sometimes you are in a
very good shape but
physically but your mind just doesn't
work that day so it's it's you have to
be a little bit lucky so everything be
together
so but yeah it's a very interesting
format and not too many people are very
good at this format so it's an
interesting way to follow a chess
well i think that chess strength
generally translate across all formats
so you won't see a robin blitz player
who's bad at classical chess or vice
versa you can't really search for
perfection and rapture with some
controls especially in blitz you have to
rely more on your feeling and
throw caution to wins to the winds a bit
more if you try to you know control
everything and make sure everything's
perfect then you run the risk
and the likelihood that you'll run into
severe time trouble and even if you've
played a perfect game and you're totally
winning just one blunder is enough to to
ruin a flawless game and to lose game
i think you know it's like
i think it started covering yeah who
said like there are like
three you know
three most important things which which
is just player
should have to be successful it's luck
luck and luck
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the last round of the
first day of the blitz and here are your
standings with alireza in absolutely
dominant position there and also frankly
if not for the existence of hikaru
nakamura crushing this blitz tournament
he's on six out of eight but he carries
on six and a half which is what uh why
is that happening is because if you look
at the very very bottom you see sam
shanklin and lanier dominguez are
basically gifting away a lot of points
yeah
for for two people to be on whatever it
is plus uh
plus five and plus four respectively
somebody has to be in a huge minus and
you have two people who are having an
absolute nightmare today losing losing
you know great great waves of games our
final round of the day
around nine coming up and uh take a look
at our pairings and tell us who you like
is our marquee matchup uh here we have
uh shaq playing white against fabi mbl
shankland linear is playing against
already a tale of you know very very
contrasting tournaments right nipomnishi
white against uh devon ironian and
jeffrey strong playing against hikaru
and i think this one is
the one to watch because jeffrey is
actually well tied for third in the
blitz tournament on five out of eight
with uh yandy bomnishi having a very
very solid tournament so far
unexpectedly i think you sort of by this
point just assume
any of the younger generation will be
very very strong blitz players and
jeffrey is no exception uh there as a
wildcard player he's certainly holding
his own against this very very elite uh
group
uh he car who should be happy but boy i
tell you i look at hicario i don't
detect
uh
any sense of uh joy going on there
christians i mean just very focused he
came into this event knowing that he
needs two days of perfect chess pretty
much to be able to get back into the mix
and try to win this competition he knows
that the job is not done even if he wins
this game he's still very far away from
alireza and make no mistake about it
hikaru still wants to win this
tournament absolutely yeah yeah
and uh
if he gets close enough and they both
continue playing the way they're playing
today
it could really develop into a somewhat
unexpected two-horse race you know
considering that you know they started
today
you know
first and last places yeah exactly he's
not there yet he's still only i think
fifth in uh in the standings right now
but
uh you know if if he wins this game he
he will he'll have scored seven and a
half out of nine today remark which is a
remarkable score yeah e4 yeah no no
berlin for you mr shum wow
and the carol khan yeah yeah will we see
e5 knight of three i guess a5 i guess
queen a5 queen a5 i i in a five
no no no not queen of five no it exists
what is it
it does
it's a stupid move but it exists yeah
and even that stupid move has a name
what's that it's not the purple i'm not
sure yeah and now we will just get a
kind of an old indian right yeah queen
c7 d4 d6 some kind of a setup like this
yeah it's a it's not the philadelphia
because there's a c2 on c4 yeah will he
go for the uh h6 g5 lines will he play
kind of a solid position because i think
i think if you play the solid version
also there's some hint of default bishop
before maybe queen c7 makes me think
maybe he wants to play bishop before
because otherwise he would have just
played d6 previously of course
capturing you you mean like you capture
now you don't play bishop b4 right away
here yeah if you really if you if you
capture and then go bishop before i
think that makes very
little sense i have to say that was a
good pick for the game of the round
because this is such a wild position
there it is yeah default bishop before
basically saying yeah i mean this
probably doesn't equalize it's probably
i mean it doesn't equalize probably
pushing it very mildly wait a minute
wait a minute it takes 24 for instance
yeah yeah knight c3 b7 kwinji 4g6 and we
go right because really oh boy it feels
like a couple of simultaneous games
yeah and we go but the point is if you
don't lose immediately which you might
no you don't castle you just go i think
g66 or something right or actually you
can you can play castles bishop h6 g6
but i think you get mated it's not that
you lose the exchange i think you you
know no trades on c3
somehow hikaru is playing like he
actually knows what he's doing i'm
pretty sure kind of doubt i think i
think he does by the way no games this
is a normal
novelty
uh in this knight c3 was the uh the move
played
yeah and i think this is something that
perhaps he's looked at specifically as a
kind of a one-off blitz thing to do
you like you you don't do this in a
classical game but
uh but it's it's something that might
just be uh
you know playable for playable once in
your life i'm curious can i play three
uh
might be three queen g4 but i think 96
would still be the choice it might be
396. we go back to g2
i think it's just a very exciting choice
to play
i like your thinking
jeffrey says no no queen to do for you
yeah let's play let's play very actively
which i think is the right call
black is severely underdeveloped there
is no point to introducing people
which makes me want to try to develop
with d7d6
yeah
karu like magnus at times does have some
strain he's played some really really
trolly openings specifically against
jeffrey he's played some very very
trolly openings but this is this is
different this is like a semi-series
like compared to some of the other stuff
he has done over the years
this is not that stupid like if you play
queen g3 here i will castle enough to
bishop d3 i think i have a 5.
and
and then a 504 is a very serious threat
um
if if white finishes development white
will of course be quite safely and
risk-free better but right
this really does feel like a somewhat
thought out blitz opening for a couple
of games which hikaru is now
demonstrating quick question for you
queen takes e7 are you capturing
recapturing with your king probably yeah
okay probably even though bishop
yeah it's fine it's fine we we can go
rook g8 we can go 97 bishop c5 yeah
couldn't you three he will castle
he will castle instantaneously i'm
pretty sure and the issue is as i
indicated i think a 504 just comes very
very quickly
and it's strange that because you're
bishop on e3 king on e1 f5 f4 is
actually a very genuine
threat i'm wondering if he's looking at
a five immediately
wow because the only reason he hasn't
castled yet in my mind is that he wants
to even improve on that by playing a
five it already creates a threat over
four because there's a king only one
that castles indeed yeah and then if you
play let's say bishop i will castle and
i will have the same position with the
bishop on e2 which is even worse and now
i really think you should play five i
really remember the truth
because if you if you don't do that if
you give white time to castle and then
play it on knight 94 or knight g5
foreign it will be a very comfortable
yeah exactly it will be a very
comfortable position for white right but
f5 generates but maybe it doesn't maybe
i can customize four queens
five on the board oh no pardon me that's
my analysis for it i apologize yeah but
there's five there it is yeah i mean i
was i was willing to bet money on this
being the next move
like nothing else makes sense hard cold
cash yeah i mean nothing else makes
sense and this
makes a ton of sense as well yeah three
minutes to two and a half
did uh did he catch uh
jeffrey a little bit unawares jeffrey
has only one definitely yeah only one
only one move yes
yeah and it's so it's a movie you don't
particularly like to make because the
queen was there just a moment ago i
think you have to go back right queen h4
yeah and you're still fine but it's
clearly a victory like an opening
victory for black because black i think
is very safely fine right so the entire
gamble absolutely paid off
it often is the case that those one-off
tries
end up being very good and then people
try it themselves and fail
by the way jeffrey did play the movie he
didn't play he's a queen age he's an
objective young man he understands that
he probably messed up he's no longer
better but you know that's still no
reason to be worse right you still want
to continue playing the game so queen
takes h4 knight takes h4 and g6 sorry
i don't know if i wanted to play
pressing i actually would like to
restrict both the knight on c3 and the
bishop on d3 i actually like g6 much
better than i like a4 just controlling
the e4 just typing the bishop on d3 or
knight c5 which is another they're also
very nice actually
95 bishop c2 i'm not sure that's you
the knight was so such a great shakes on
e6 i don't know i
i should prefer g6 to this because now
if the bishop c2 what will be
intending to play a3 and with the pawn
on the 5 i'm not very happy with the
idea of trading my bishop before for the
knight on c3 and leaving myself with
those
gaping holes in the dark squares which
will not be really
coverable by by any of our pieces uh
gaping holes uh bishop c2 bishop e6 not
an issue maybe ah jeffrey just disagrees
with all of us and gives up that bishop
for wow for the night bishop b6 play
this is a very comfortable end game now
again yes
get rid of this maybe oh please
what have i done it was my
screen uh skew uh b397
you sort of prefer this for blick maybe
oh definitely i'm looking at knight e5
as a temple by the way they're the night
on seasons
you better get that knight out and dodge
there because that bishop on c3 was
being
really an aggressive 95 frog d1 bishop
e7 but luckily for white we have bishop
nobish before knight takes c4
again say that again knight five yes
rook g1 okay we should be seven
what am i doing with yeah
bishop
all right we're just foreign with black
that's upon yeah yeah
i think we're just significantly like if
if he finds and plays the sequence i see
i've seen no except it's a meter
or 95 95 at tempo yeah so i guess after
a b7 i just have to go knight neither
four i think maybe is still kind of
recovering and then the bishop goes to
e7 asks this knight what you're going to
do but even at knight f4 can you take on
c4 with the bishop obviously c8 even
yeah
there's still no equality of white i
think white is just worse after wars
after which b7 but he's played something
i think he's got knight takes c4 which
is a very very concrete solution by the
way guys just to give you an update yeah
with the black pieces is winning against
dominguez
who has
who has really slipped he has 27 seconds
right now dominguez alireza with 2
minutes and 37 seconds and a dominating
position this is not looking good for
lanier did lanier start with a draw yeah
then follow up with a lot
that's a bad day
uh
big issues here uh hikaru is picking up
uh two pawns yeah i actually
i mean he's gonna he's going to be fine
but i don't know if that was the best he
had because uh
white will have some yeah b65 now very
very important to restrict the bishop on
e3 but he sounds like it feels like
maybe white isn't really doing that
horribly two pieces for uh
oh uh even at the cost of yeah yeah i'm
playing rook id right here so quick
like i'm playing rook here like
no pause
no no hesitation at the end just give me
dr strangelove
yeah although i mean knight five my
issue is if i go rook g1 rk1 there in
the end 97 knight take c6 probably does
make a draw oh wow so you do have to
perhaps consider it a little bit but i'm
still yeah he decides yeah but now he
can do it next move right you'll just
play rook fd8 here
he's pausing
i
think done it oh okay now kg8 where are
we i think we're winning with black now
now it's a big difference because the
rook will actually be
super active yeah bishop takes a four is
unplayable you have to play king e2 and
try to preserve the a2 upon if you lose
the eight pawn you lose the card
three three passers yeah but uh yeah
yeah
rook a4 it's one of my king e2 it's one
of my absolute what no he allowed
one yeah this is over
whoa so he took on f4 that was
that was a shocker you said it the
christian three connected past bonds
you can't survive this you won't be able
to run no i don't think this is
survivable and this is one of my one of
my you know all-time favorite hobby
horses the the subject of absolutely
needing to have a rook on the board if
you are the side with the two light
pieces against the rogue two light
pieces against the rook is tremendous
trouble for you a rook and two light
pieces against two rooks is survivable
very often exactly because you have a
piece to deal with the active rogues
exactly uh yeah so him you know pushing
the rook on an open file there for me
was just like an instant dominguez is
back in the game
against alireza right now wow and
actually has a pretty decent chance to
potentially uh win that game
we really think that this is over i mean
the yeah
yeah i think
it's just going to go a3 a2 rook b1 yeah
we can definitely switch to that other
one because this is over yeah we know
how this movie ends
it's not a brilliant ending and i think
we should just we're going to go up to
the lanier apologies for to everybody
who really enjoying this uh show if you
will by hikaru ooh uh g4
what is going on here lanier yeah it
looks like he's attacking i think he is
back to being lost yeah because the king
will be safe on d6 he probably missed in
some way today f2 is hanging yeah
oh
so on the analysis board we have the
game between dominions and furuja on the
main board the game between jeffrey and
nakamura exactly yeah both of which will
most likely be won by by the way jeffrey
is trying to do something with that f
pawn though it's not enough but f7 is
not really a threat even you can allow
f6 f7 you still exactly you still
haven't generated enough of a threat
so just go if a2 here f6 i don't know f6
anything to be said no i was about to do
rookie three
okay we'll jump back uh to uh
the game we've been watching
and ferruja actually won his game as uh
ali reza farouja our tournament leader
has won
yet again
ooh
c3 c3 i'm not sure
if seven [ __ ]
i don't know why we're doing it this way
but that's a check you're going to be
couple
yeah huge victory bravo hikaru seven and
a half out of nine immediately
remarkable score by hikari
we still have some live games going on
this is a shock against uh this will be
a draw let's go to the
mvl versus shankling game because that
one has some content left
not much this looks like one of those
colors this should be a draw right yeah
yeah things are things are disappearing
pretty fast yeah yeah
things are disappearing pretty fast
and this concludes our day with ali rez
in an absolutely dominant position uh
hikaru scored seven and a half out of
nine which is tremendous and there's a
score at seven
which is why he's in first place which
is why he's like three points clear of
the field yeah because in the rapids he
underperformed uh
uh
terribly uh sorry christian uh give us a
review of this final round uh it wasn't
uh all decisive but it sure felt like
black one
no no absolutely i mean this one between
jeffrey and hikari you guys were
spending quite a lot of time on this one
sure but dominguez versus fuja let's
take a look at what happened here big
swings it felt like they were playing
some sort of a theoretical battle in
this djoko piano c6 bishop to c2 but
once again i was
looking at their time spencer and it was
dominguez was falling behind severely on
his clock we already see him under four
minutes right now and with every move
alireza was creating some separation on
the clock this was uh his nemesis
dominguez's nemesis in today's rounds
just his time spencer was not up to par
knight to e6 knight to g3 f6 still
within some sort of uh theoretical
battle bishop to f5 would have been the
best move in the position and pretty
much the only move actually in the
position to maintain some sort of a
balance knight to f5 after taking on e5
knight takes e5
he was supposed to take with the rook
but already the position becomes a bit
quite unpleasant for white because you
have to tend to the fact that this pawn
on d4 is going to be a weakness forever
now without the pawn on e5 this bishop
could potentially find another home on
the b8 h2 diagonal and potentially
create a strong battery with the queen
as well and your attack on the king's
side despite the fact that you have a
lot of forces swarming around my king is
not as powerful you don't have a very
good coordination of your pieces he did
not play this move he took with the
knight and after g6 unfortunately
he loses uh the pawn on d4 and this
comes with tremendous consequences rook
to e6 taking on g4 perhaps not the most
precise move in the position and after
rook to e1 rook to e8 this was a huge uh
blunder for ali reza he was supposed to
just challenge this rook on the g file
with the move rook to g8 after rook h8
queen takes g8 it does feel like the
king is quite safe with the only piece
that is not playing the rook on a8
coming into the game in one move after
route 28 the king is going to be saved
with so many defenders around him
unfortunately he did not do that rook 28
was played and this allowed him back
into the game dominguez back into the
game but once again queen to e3 was a
bad move bishop to h7 a very difficult
move to see it's all about creating
threats in this position if you miss one
tempo if you miss one bit and you don't
create the threat of course the threat
i'm talking about is rook to g8 and pick
up little a8 well unfortunately if you
miss that one bit you're going to be
losing this would have allowed him to
equalize actually this position after
king f7 just bishop to g6 back into f8
bishop to h7 and maybe we would have
seen uh unequal game and ali reza being
stopped in the last round but what a
performance for this young men as well
as for hikaru nakamura the pineapple
shirt power is coming to life pineapple
express thank you for that christian and
uh we're going to share with you uh the
topsy-turvy world of
of uh blitz chess as a queen
trap
comes on the board here and yeah
yeah bishop one trying to create space
for the queen void g5 g4 but bishop g4
is a bit of a problem yeah kind of like
enjoying the moment not a bad move i get
it i get it
but now comes
where would you like to put your queen
bishop g4 yeah i left
really enjoying the moment
he's coming to grips with the new with a
new situation on the board and yeah and
bishop g4 is going to come as a bit of a
cold shower there
am i somewhat shocked at how long it
took him to play it honestly
boy i mean
i would have been johnny johnny on the
spot with this one
i don't think he's oh okay he's seen it
now yeah
yeah yeah
and john just started i think he starts
laughing again i think there's a yeah
he's just laughing uh
yeah yeah but we have a very special
guest since judy he may not be leading
the tournament but he's certainly
leading the blitz uh christian with
ikaru hikaru first of all
congratulations a dominant performance
in today's rounds how did you come
to how did you approach today's rounds
yeah i mean you just try to approach it
where you play chess i mean it really
could not have gone worse than it did
for me in the rapid portion so just
tried to play play good shots i mean i
think really the main thing though is
when when you aren't playing well you
just want to get off to a good start and
uh with the two whites to start if i if
i didn't win like one or both of those
games i think it could have been a long
day but fortunately i did and the rest
was was pretty smooth i mean in a way i
wish i had won this game against yon but
at the same time i also should have lost
lenie so sort of offsets you also uh
brought a superpower in today's rounds
the pineapple shirt tell us a bit about
the story behind that yeah i mean that's
i guess already a couple years ago now
in 2020 when i was streaming um and many
of many of the streams i was doing i was
wearing the pineapple shirt it became
this meme from this famous streamer uh
forsen's chat and it's kind of stuck
stuck with me and then i've just you
know taken advantage of it since then
but it you know it's it's a side thing
but it wasn't it didn't play a huge role
in my success today i'll say that at the
beginning of today's rounds did you
harbor any hopes of potentially winning
the tournament or was that in the back
of your mind yeah i mean i think uh it's
it's happened in a couple of grand
chester events where players have been
way behind after the rap and they score
they have a really big score i don't
think they've ever come back to win i
mean it would be pretty amazing from
last to first um
that wasn't really in my mind i mean i
think the leader stumble they stumbled
but i just wanted to play good shots
because i felt that much of the um many
of the issues in the rapid were
self-inflicted i mean i found a way to
lose a couple of games that i definitely
should never have lost um fabiano game
was was of course really really poor
even at the end but yes played good
chess and things seemed to go my way for
the most part i mean i thought it was
very smooth only the game against lenie
was sort of up and down but otherwise i
i had great positions and i mean again
when you do so poorly in the rapid it
doesn't get worse so i just tried to
play my best you dominated uh today's
rounds but also the leader ali raza
firuja has had a fantastic day how do
you assess his performance yeah i mean
what he got seven so obviously that's a
very good score um
yeah i mean he's he played well in the
rap and he's playing well on the blitz
and i think actually getting back to my
own result that's why i was so so
annoyed about about this game against um
fabiano and also sam for that matter
because the thing is no one's running
away with running away with the event so
it's very very bunched up and and if you
just can put points on the board and
then give yourself give yourself a
chance in the blitz anything can happen
um
so that's why i was annoyed but yeah for
ali reza obviously he's having a great
event both in the rapid and the blitz
and i mean he's a deserved leader right
now so we'll see what happens tomorrow
picaro still nine rounds to go get some
rest we'll see you tomorrow thank you
well played sir well done hicaro yes
indeed uh seven and a
half and there you have it and there you
have it on your screen uh three draws
there mixed in and uh
six victories an extremely extremely
impressive performance by hikaru yes
indeed
just
fabulous
[Music]
and uh here are your standings after the
first day of blitz nine rounds to go
with those nine rounds to go alireza is
on 18 out of 29 available points maximum
full three points behind and actually
hey
top five top three
that was your prediction when hikara
started from the last yeah you said well
no i i i did i did say that with him
winning the first two but still yeah
yeah clear third now starting from the
clear last place half a point the head
of yanni pomniche and jeffrey sean who
continued to be having a decent
tournament but could have gone better
the crazy part is at a certain moment
hikaru was three points behind alireza
and he
was continuing
great and now he's three and a half
points behind him why
because
yeah one is his last four one the one
when the last four yeah just just wow
randomly goes on a tear and just
destroys the field
remarkable the young man is playing well
he really really is playing
just as hikaru described it himself very
well i mean he's deserving of his place
yeah in the position in the tournament
very much very much so and tomorrow
uh
it really does feel like it feels a bit
unfair to the rest of the field but it
really does feel that
if alireza continues playing the way
he's been playing the tournament is his
leaders
yeah but if not hikaru could be the one
maybe to to try and catch him and we
have alireza in the studio as well so
let's talk to our leader ali reza first
of all congratulations an incredible
performance for you today how do you
assess this result and what did you do
to prepare for uh such a day
yeah i'm very happy with my performance
um
i think
continuing zagreb it was a
it was a good progress because the first
day of zagreb it was very bad but the
second day was the same as here so
um yeah in the blitz you should really
have the day so
i was lucky that i was in a good mood
today
and
yeah it was a very good performance i
guess
you also never lost touch with that
leadership position starting after day
one you were maybe close with mvl but
never lost touch with that leadership
position was that part of your strategy
and was that important for you yeah of
course it's important to keep the
leadership but the worst the there is of
course
bad thing about being leader all the
rounds is that everybody is looking at
you who wants to
catch you in the playing all day look
a little bit so
strange to me but
um yeah in general i think it's
difficult to handle the lead in this
kind of tournaments but i'm happy that i
managed until here so but there is nine
rounds to go for
absolutely still nine rounds to go a
very hot hikaru nakamura did you expect
to see hikaru heat up like that
yeah of course i was expecting this
that's why i wanted to
get a big lead in the rapid for from him
because he's always
putting these kind of performances in
blitz so yeah i'm not shocked i think
he's
world number one in blitz i think number
two so number one yeah yeah number one
so it's pretty normal i guess steven
nine runs to go we'll let you go get
some rest congratulations we'll see you
tomorrow
our congratulations as well a very very
nice performance only overshadowed just
a little bit by uh
wow uh like you say our apologies to
everybody else it's not just going to be
a two horse race tomorrow i mean there
are other players in the field but it's
just that those two gentlemen put up
such big scores yeah and
mvl
has been known to score unbelievable
amounts of points as well but
so far it seems like the two the two
absolutely informed players judging by
this you know we'll we'll see and uh
here's our predictions which are looking
yeah i'm less good
after today
but but it's okay i mean you know it's
nice to have you you know competing with
us
[Laughter]
we'll see we'll see i mean but uh
christian your final thoughts for a very
uh enjoyable uh blitz start no
absolutely just an amazing day of chess
we expected uh that we always expect
here at the granchester this rapid and a
blitz tournament to be extremely
explosive and this is exactly what we're
getting and it's tremendous to see
hikaru just a stringing victory after a
victory and bringing his very confident
self back also the same it feels like
we're watching history in the making
with this uh young talent ali reza
firuja who is just becoming such a
powerhouse this is going to be a
fantastic end of the tournament in
tomorrow's rounds and we'll be here to
call all the action very very very well
put indeed thank you everybody uh for
sharing your day with us be sure
to tell everybody where you've been
hanging out and we'll see you all
tomorrow see you tomorrow
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the
saint louis chess club any reproduction
or distribution of this content without
the express written consent of the saint
louis chess club is prohibited